Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the rest is history.com and join the club. That is the rest is history.com. This episode is brought to you by Hive. You know, history is full of transformations. The Romans shifted from Republic to Empire. the Tudor's transformed monasteries into country houses. And do you know what? Hive has had one of its own. Everybody knows Hive for smart thermostats, but now they've evolved into something much greater. Solar panels that help you to power your home with clean energy. Heat pumps that pull warmth from thin air.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。本期节目由 Hive 赞助。你知道，历史充满了变革。罗马人从共和国转变为帝国，都铎王朝将修道院改造成了乡村别墅。你知道吗？Hive 也经历了自己的变革。大家都知道 Hive 的智能恒温器，但现在他们已经进化得更强大了。太阳能电池板能帮你用清洁能源为家庭供电，热泵能从稀薄的空气中汲取热量。
EV charges that charge your car while you're asleep. All managed through a single app. This is all about giving people the power to transform their homes, from waste to efficiency, from dependence to control, from consumption to contribution. So history's next great transformation may not be happening in parliaments or palaces. It may be happening in your home. A quiet revolution minus guillotine's. Hive. Know your power. Visit hivehome.com to find out more. Subject to survey and suitability, Hive app compatible with selected heat pumps. This episode is brought to you by SAP. With investors, customers, and workers demanding more from your business, it's time to try SAP. Its AI-powered capabilities can help you streamline costs, connect with new suppliers, and manage payroll even when your business is being pulled in different directions, to deliver a quality product at a fair price, while paying your people what they're worth too, so your business can stay unfazed. more at SAP.com
在你睡觉时为汽车充电的电动汽车充电桩，所有这些都通过一个应用程序进行管理。这一切都是为了赋予人们改造家庭的能力，从浪费到高效，从依赖到掌控，从消费到贡献。所以，历史下一次伟大的变革可能不会发生在议会或宫殿里，它可能就发生在你家里。一场没有断头台的静默革命。Hive。了解你的力量。访问 hivehome.com 了解更多信息。需视勘测和适用性而定，Hive 应用程序兼容部分热泵。本期节目由 SAP 赞助。随着投资者、客户和员工对你的业务提出更高要求，是时候尝试 SAP 了。其人工智能驱动的功能可以帮助你精简成本、对接新供应商并管理工资单，即使在你的业务面临多方压力时，也能以合理的价格提供优质产品，同时给予员工应有的报酬，让你的业务保持从容。更多信息请访问 SAP.com
slash uncertainty. Craving an escape. Bring the vibrant flavors of Mexican street eat energy to life in your kitchen with Tia Rosa tortillas. Born in Mexico, Tia Rosa knows how to turn
消除不确定性。渴望逃离？用 Tia Rosa 玉米饼在你的厨房里重现墨西哥街头美食的活力。源自墨西哥，Tia Rosa 知道如何将
your next taco night at home into the real deal. Find Tia Rosa Tartillas at select grocery stores and get the good vibes going. Paris. A lovely morning in the spring of 1801, the trees heavy with cherry blossom, the sunlight dancing on the River Sen, the soldiers exercising their horses in the palace courtyard. From a first floor window, a man was watching the horseman.
你下一次在家举办的塔可之夜变成地道的体验。在指定杂货店寻找 Tia Rosa 玉米饼，开启美好氛围。巴黎。1801 年春的一个可爱早晨，树上挂满了樱花，阳光在塞纳河上跳跃，士兵们在宫殿庭院里训练马匹。从二楼的窗户，一个男人正在注视着骑兵。
He wore a long red silk coat, white stockings and black shoes. and he had tucked his left hand inside his jacket. His lank, dark hair was cut short, Roman style, and his grey eyes were narrowed in thought. At 31, Napoleon Bonaparte, First Consul of France, had come a long way from the back streets of Corsica. Yet despite his victories, one country still defied him.
他穿着一件长款红色丝绸外套、白色长袜和黑色鞋子，左手插在夹克里。他那稀疏的深色头发剪得很短，是罗马风格，灰色的眼睛眯着，陷入了沉思。31 岁的拿破仑·波拿巴，法兰西第一执政，从科西嘉岛的后街一路走来，已经取得了巨大的成就。然而，尽管他战功赫赫，仍有一个国家在反抗他。
Britain, a nation of shopkeepers, he thought scornfully, who cared more for mills and manufactories than for blood and battles. He crossed to his dressing table and picked up a little marble bust. There was just one Englishman who made a worthy opponent, their great hero, their supposed saviour, this fellow Nelson. But one day when the banners of France flew over London, this little sailor would kneel before him, just like all the rest. So Dominic, I think that final sentence is possibly the most chilling that we've ever read out on the rest of history. And it is, of course, from your adventures in time, Nelson, Hero of the Seas, which came out in paperback a week ago. And it is a reminder, if any, were needed, of just how
英国，一个店主组成的国家，他轻蔑地想，他们比起鲜血和战斗，更关心磨坊和工厂。他走到梳妆台前，拿起一个小理石半身像。只有一个英国人算得上是值得尊敬的对手，他们伟大的英雄，他们所谓的救世主，这个叫纳尔逊的家伙。但总有一天，当法国的旗帜在伦敦上空飘扬时，这个小水手会像其他人一样跪在他面前。所以多米尼克，我认为最后那句话可能是我们在《历史的余味》中读到过的最令人不寒而栗的一句。当然，它出自你的《时间冒险：纳尔逊，海洋英雄》，这本书一周前刚出平装本。如果还需要提醒的话，这提醒了我们
high the stakes are for Britain during what are now called the Napoleonic Wars. And we ended last time in the summer of 1801. Nelson has redeemed himself. He's once again enshrined as the great hero of England after his victory at the Battle of Copenhagen. And we described him coming back to England, being greeted at Yarmouth, lots of Hazars and cheers and all of that. But Britain is a miserable, exhausted, depressed.
在现在被称为拿破仑战争的时期，英国面临的赌注有多高。我们上次结束于 1801 年夏天。纳尔逊已经完成了自我救赎。在哥本哈根战役胜利后，他再次被尊为英国的伟大英雄。我们描述了他回到英国，在雅茅斯受到欢迎，伴随着欢呼声等等。但英国是一个悲惨、疲惫、沮丧、
overtaxed country. So obviously nothing like Britain now. Oh, you've gone there. Unbelievable. Yes. Yeah, most people are sick of the war by now. So the war's been going on for eight years. Napoleon, of course, across the channel. His eyes are fixed on Britain. But war weariness rather than war enthusiasm is the order of the day in London and beyond. So there's a new Prime Minister, Henry Addington, who has replaced William Pitt the Younger, after a big row about Catholic emancipation. And one of Addington's defining characteristics is that he's seen as more moderate, so more likely actually to reach a compromise with the new dictator of France.
税负沉重的国家。所以显然和现在的英国一点也不像。哦，你提到这个了。难以置信。是的。大多数人现在已经厌倦了战争。战争已经持续了八年。拿破仑当然就在海峡对面。他的目光锁定在英国。但在伦敦及其他地区，战争疲劳感取代了战争热情。所以有一位新首相亨利·阿丁顿，他取代了小威廉·皮特，此前因为天主教解放问题发生了大争吵。阿丁顿的一个显著特征是，他被认为更温和，因此实际上更有可能与法国的新独裁者达成妥协。
The question is whether Napoleon wants a compromise at all. He's been first consul since 1799. Military victory, military glory is his corner. card. And has he given up on the idea of defeating Britain by land and sea? No. Because when Nelson reaches the Admiralty at the beginning of July, his very disturbing news while he's been away in the Baltic. Bonaparte has been mustering his invasion force. The official French government newspaper Le Monitre has published an appeal for men to join this gigantic army. There have been reports that in the northern ports of France, there are huge press gangs enlisting people
问题在于拿破仑是否真的想要妥协。他自 1799 年以来一直担任第一执政。军事胜利、军事荣耀是他的王牌。他放弃了通过陆路和海路击败英国的想法了吗？没有。因为当纳尔逊在 7 月初到达海军部时，他在波罗的海期间收到了一些非常令人不安的消息。波拿巴一直在集结他的入侵部队。法国官方报纸《通报》发表了一份呼吁，号召人们加入这支庞大的军队。有报道称，在法国北部港口，有大规模的强征兵役，招募人员
for the invasion. And the British newspapers are full of stories about what Bonaparte and his fellow revolutionary enthusiasts will do when they get to London. Yeah, so they're in a massive flap. And I guess that, I mean, the salient fact that everyone is aware of in Paris and in London is the fact that a successful French crossing of the channel, the transportation of an army from France to English soil, is really the one operation that could end the war in a single day. Because all Napoleon needs to do is to get a force onto English soil. Britain's military forces are puny compared to those under Napoleon's command.
准备入侵。英国报纸上充斥着关于波拿巴和他的革命狂热分子到达伦敦后会做什么的故事。是的，所以他们陷入了巨大的恐慌。我想，巴黎和伦敦每个人都意识到的一个显著事实是，法国成功横渡海峡，将军队从法国运送到英国本土，这确实是唯一可能在一天之内结束战争的行动。因为拿破仑所要做的就是让部队踏上英国土地。与拿破仑指挥下的军队相比，英国的军事力量微不足道。
And then if he can seize control of the naval bases directly in their path, above all the bases of the bases at the... the Knorr, so on the Thames Estuary, and Chatham, you know, epic theme of a recent episode. Right, listeners will remember. These dockyards are the great smithes of British independence and status
如果他能夺取通往他们路径上的海军基地，最重要的是位于泰晤士河口和查塔姆的基地，你知道，这是最近一期节目的史诗主题。没错，听众们会记得。这些造船厂是英国独立和地位的伟大锻造厂，
as a superpower. If they can be knocked out, then Britain effectively is knocked out as a rival to France. And it's game over. So it's understandable that people in Britain would be in a panic, And it's understandable that Napoleon, who, of course, has had a massive run in with the Royal Navy at the Battle of the Nile, caused him all kinds of problems.
作为超级大国。如果它们被摧毁，那么英国作为法国竞争对手的地位实际上也就被摧毁了。游戏就结束了。所以英国人感到恐慌是可以理解的，而拿破仑，当然，他在尼罗河战役中与皇家海军发生过大规模冲突，这给他造成了各种各样的问题。
It's understandable that Napoleon would be keen to kind of seize this opportunity to end the war in a day. I think something for listeners to get into their minds is that if you, especially British listeners, if you think about the spirit of 1940, Dunkirk and the Battle of Britain and the possibility that Hitler will strike at any moment and the sort of Churchillian spirit. If you imagine that, but not just in one summer, but in year after year during the Napoleonic Wars, with sort of peaks. And this is one of those peaks. Yeah, invasion scares. Invasion scares. So Addington's government has already put in place preparations for the invasion. They've called up volunteers.
拿破仑渴望抓住这个机会在一天之内结束战争是可以理解的。我认为听众们需要记住的一点是，如果你，特别是英国听众，如果你想到 1940 年的精神，敦刻尔克和不列颠战役，希特勒随时可能发动袭击的可能性，以及那种丘吉尔式的精神。如果你想象一下，不是仅仅在一个夏天，而是在拿破仑战争期间年复一年，伴随着各种高峰。而这就是其中一个高峰。是的，入侵恐慌。入侵恐慌。所以阿丁顿政府已经为入侵做好了准备。他们召集了志愿者。
They've driven loads of livestock inland away from the coast. They've barricaded the main roads from the channel ports. But actually, to go back to the 1940 parallel, as in 1940, there is a sense of. that the political establishment wants to find a figurehead to inspire the people, to fill the people with confidence in this darkest hour. Who could that person be? It's only one candidate, isn't there? And that's the person who won the Battle of the Nile and the Battle of Copenhagen, Horatio Nelson,
他们把大量的牲畜赶到远离海岸的内陆。他们封锁了从海峡港口通往内陆的主要道路。但实际上，回到 1940 年的类比，就像 1940 年一样，有一种感觉，政治建制派想要找到一个领袖来激励人民，在最黑暗的时刻给人民注入信心。那个人会是谁呢？只有一个候选人，不是吗？那就是赢得了尼罗河战役和哥本哈根战役的霍雷肖·纳尔逊，
who has returned exhausted, but straight away he's offered this job that's created especially for him by his old boss, Lord St. Vincent, formerly Sir John Jervis. They say, we'll make you commander of the defences of the mouths of the River Thames and the River Medway as well as the coasts of Sussex, Kemp, and Essex. So it's a new kind of job for Nelson this. Well, it's defensive, isn't it? Right, exactly. He's on the attack. There's a land element.
他疲惫地归来，但立刻被他的老上司圣文森特勋爵（前约翰·杰维斯爵士）委以重任，这个职位是专门为他设立的。他们说，我们将让你担任泰晤士河口和梅德韦河口以及苏塞克斯、肯特和埃塞克斯海岸防御的指挥官。所以这对纳尔逊来说是一份新工作。嗯，这是防御性的，不是吗？没错，正是如此。他一直在进攻。这里有一个陆地因素。
He's never good on land, as we will discover. So it sounds quite Churchillian, but there are definitely downsides. So one downside is that the men they give him for the job are absolutely useless. Well, they have a ludicrous name, don't they? The sea fensibles. It looks like something out of a nursery rhyme. Went to sea in a pea green boat or something. Well, that's basically the vibe.
正如我们将要发现的那样，他在陆地上从不擅长。所以这听起来很像丘吉尔，但肯定有缺点。一个缺点是他们给他的手下完全没用。嗯，他们的名字很荒谬，不是吗？“海上自卫队”（Sea Fensibles）。看起来像是童谣里的东西。坐着豌豆绿小船出海什么的。嗯，基本上就是那种氛围。
So they give them the sea fensibles. So basically, the way it works is if all your navy is at sea, and you're about to be invaded by the French, they call for the sea fensibles. And these are basically oyster men. It's dad's navy. Yeah, exactly. He's dad's navy, exactly.
所以他们给了他海上自卫队。所以基本上，运作方式是如果你们所有的海军都在海上，而你即将被法国人入侵，他们就会呼吁海上自卫队。这些人基本上是牡蛎捕捞者。这是“爸爸的海军”。是的，没错。这是爸爸的海军，完全正确。
They're like old watermen, fishermen and whatnot. None of whom want to be there at all. They hate being called up. They hate the discipline of the Royal Navy. And some of them, my favorite fact about them, is that there was one of Nelson's officers complained. He said, a very large proportion of the sea fensibles under my command have got only one leg. So they have wooden legs.
他们就像老船夫、渔民之类的。他们中没有人想待在那里。他们讨厌被征召。他们讨厌皇家海军的纪律。其中一些人，关于他们我最喜欢的事实是，纳尔逊的一名军官抱怨说。他说，我指挥下的海上自卫队中有很大一部分人只有一条腿。所以他们有木腿。
And basically, whenever we put to sea, they all fall over. So they have to stay below decks because they're kind of lurching around the deck. But I suppose, I mean, they're space if they're firing cannon, they could just be plonked down next to the cannon. Theo is saying, are they press ganged into it? Yes, they're basically, they don't really get any choice. They're very disgruntled because they're not, you know, they're taken away from making their livelihood.
基本上，每当我们出海时，他们都会摔倒。所以他们必须待在甲板下，因为他们在甲板上摇摇晃晃。但我猜，我是说，如果他们是在发射大炮，他们可以被安置在大炮旁边。西奥在说，他们是被强征入伍的吗？是的，他们基本上没有选择。他们非常不满，因为他们没有，你知道，他们被从生计中拉走了。
So they're not really making much money from this. They're paid as sort of pittance. And meanwhile, you talked about, you know, people without legs and stuff. Yeah. Nelson, of course, hasn't got his arm, hasn't got his eye. Yeah. And as we heard at the end of the last episode, his hypochondria, or is it hypochondria, is absolute peak?
所以他们并没有从这上面赚到多少钱。他们得到的报酬微薄。与此同时，你谈到了，你知道，没有腿的人之类的。是的。纳尔逊当然没有手臂，没有眼睛。是的。正如我们在上一集结尾听到的那样，他的疑病症，或者说是疑病症，达到了顶峰？
I mean, is he actually ill? I mean, is he in any fit state? to take up this position? He's in no-fit state. He's got eye infection constantly. He's got these sort of night sweats. He's constantly dripping with sweat because he's got a fever. He's also seasick. I mean, this is one of the weird things about Nelson. Nelson's suffered very badly from seasickness. And he's dosing himself bizarrely with rhubarb and peppermint in an attempt to combat all these various ailments. I don't really think it works. But the bigger issue, I guess, is the thing that you alluded to. He's just not very good on the defensive.
我是说，他真的病了吗？我是说，他处于适合担任这个职位的状态吗？他根本不适合。他有持续的眼部感染。他有那种盗汗。他总是汗流浃背，因为他发烧了。他还晕船。我是说，这是纳尔逊奇怪的地方之一。纳尔逊患有严重的晕船症。他奇怪地给自己服用大黄和薄荷，试图对抗所有这些各种各样的疾病。我真的不认为这有效。但我猜更大的问题是你提到的那件事。他只是不太擅长防御。
attack is his, you know, it's his instinct. But, I mean, attack is the best form of defense, isn't it? So he has the French forces on the other side of the channel. And as he has shown at Copenhagen, he's quite good at attacking the land defenses with a naval task force. So options there, right? Yeah. And at the beginning of August, he gets some bomb vessels.
进攻是他的本能。但是，我是说，进攻是最好的防御，不是吗？所以他在海峡对面有法国军队。正如他在哥本哈根所展示的那样，他非常擅长用海军特遣部队攻击陆地防御工事。所以那里有选择，对吧？是的。在八月初，他得到了一些轰炸船。
He goes on a daring kind of intrepid raid at Boulogne. and he damages seven of the French ships and actually he comes back from that and he says to London, I don't think Napoleon is coming. I think he hasn't got anything like the invasion force, you know, especially the sort of the sea power necessary to win control of the channel and to transport his army.
他在布洛涅进行了一次大胆的突袭。他损坏了七艘法国船只，实际上他从那里回来后对伦敦说，我不认为拿破仑会来。我认为他根本没有像样的入侵部队，你知道，特别是赢得海峡控制权和运送军队所需的海上力量。
And he's right. He is right. Because actually the invasion scare is massively overblown. There's no prospect of the French coming. But the problem with this is that Nelson then succumbs to complete overconfidence. He thinks, well, Bonaparte's obviously not coming, so I might have a little crack at him myself. And he goes back to Boulogne two weeks later, 15th of August, a surprise night attack.
他是对的。他是对的。因为实际上入侵恐慌被大大夸大了。法国人没有入侵的前景。但问题在于纳尔逊随后陷入了完全的过度自信。他想，好吧，波拿巴显然不会来，所以我可以自己去试一试。两周后，即 8 月 15 日，他回到了布洛涅，进行了一次突袭。
Now, people who've been listening from the very beginning will know if there's one thing that Nelson is terrible at, it's making surprise attacks at positions on land like Tenerife. The difference this time is he's not leading it, is he? He's not standing in the boat having his arm shot off. No, he's not. And, I mean, spoiler alert, it goes catastrophically wrong. It's a disaster. And Nelson says, if only I'd been there, it would have been completely different, ignoring
现在，从一开始就一直在听的人会知道，如果说纳尔逊有什么不擅长的，那就是在特内里费岛那样的地方对陆地阵地进行突袭。这次的不同之处在于他没有亲自领导，不是吗？他没有站在船上被炸掉手臂。不，他没有。而且，我是说，剧透预警，结果灾难性地错了。这是一场灾难。纳尔逊说，如果我当时在那里，情况会完全不同，忽略了
the evidence of the fact that he very much led from the front of Tenerife. And that had been a disaster and he'd lost his arm there. And this occasion, 900 of them go. Of the 945 are killed and 128 wounded, and they don't inflict any damage really on the French at all. They come back. One of the men who dies is this young lieutenant called Edward Thornborough Parker, who had Nelson had a sort of massive, almost like a crush on this guy.
他在特内里费岛确实身先士卒的事实。那是一场灾难，他在那里失去了手臂。这次有 900 人去了。94 人死亡，128 人受伤，他们实际上根本没有对法国人造成任何伤害。他们回来了。死者中有一位年轻的中尉叫爱德华·桑伯勒·帕克，纳尔逊对这家伙有一种巨大的、几乎像是迷恋的感觉。
Like he was a massive favorite for Nelson, like a son to him. Yeah, I think it's the filial dimension of it. Because Nelson is now old. You know, he had his stepson, Josiah, who was hopeless and who he over-promoted. But Josiah did save his life, to be fair to Josiah. He did, but he proves to be a hopeless captain. And I think that's clearly one of the problems with Fanny is that she'd hasn't given him a son. And this boy, he, you know, he thinks, yeah, you know, I think he's
就像他是纳尔逊的宠儿，像儿子一样。是的，我认为这是其中的父子维度。因为纳尔逊现在老了。你知道，他有继子乔赛亚，他无可救药，而且纳尔逊过度提拔了他。但公平地说，乔赛亚确实救过他的命。他确实救过，但他证明是一个无可救药的船长。我认为这显然是范妮的问题之一，因为她没有给他生个儿子。而这个男孩，他，你知道，他认为，是的，你知道，我认为他
wonderful and then he dies. It's Nelson's fault. Nelson absolutely sobs at his funeral, makes a great spectacle of himself, and orders that a lock of Parker's hair is cut off and says, I want this hair to be buried with me. I think it actually was buried with him. So quite sort of, yeah, quite extreme. But just to stick up for Nelson's term of command as a guardian of the channel, so just to quote John Sugden, despite Boulogne, the end had been credited During his watch as the Guardian, no hostile foot had stepped on English soil, nor had a single British vessel been captured within the limits of his station. So unglomerous, but it achieves his goal.
很棒，然后他死了。这是纳尔逊的错。纳尔逊在葬礼上痛哭流涕，让自己出尽了洋相，并下令剪下一缕帕克的头发，说，我希望这缕头发和我一起埋葬。我想它确实和他一起埋葬了。所以相当，是的，相当极端。但只是为了支持纳尔逊作为海峡守护者的任期，引用约翰·萨格登的话，尽管有布洛涅事件，在他担任守护者期间，没有敌人的脚踏上过英国土地，也没有一艘英国船只在他的驻地范围内被俘。所以虽然不光彩，但它实现了目标。
There's no French invasion. So, Horace, Nelson. This is the last action of the campaign, because actually what happens at the end of September, this new Addington government signs a provisional deal with the French, which will evolve six months later into the Treaty of Amiens. And to simplify this, you know, it's a... massive simplification, but basically both sides will give up quite a lot of their conquests. So the British promised that they will give up Minorca and Malta, and the French will
没有法国入侵。所以，霍雷肖·纳尔逊。这是战役的最后行动，因为实际上在 9 月底发生的事情是，这个新的阿丁顿政府与法国签署了一项临时协议，六个月后演变成了《亚眠和约》。为了简化这一点，你知道，这是一个巨大的简化，但基本上双方都放弃了相当多的征服地。所以英国承诺放弃米诺卡岛和马耳他，法国将
withdraw their troops from central and southern Italy. Now, at the time, there are people, particularly what are then called Tories, who say, well, this is a terrible mistake. First of all, the French have been allowed to effectively keep their satellite, their puppet republics in Holland, in Switzerland and in northern Italy, and then they're not in. they can use these as a launch pad for future attacks. And more seriously, they say, this isn't going to last. Bonaparte is a monster.
从意大利中部和南部撤军。当时，有些人，特别是当时被称为托利党的人，说，这真是个可怕的错误。首先，法国人实际上被允许保留他们在荷兰、瑞士和意大利北部的卫星国、傀儡共和国，然后他们并没有撤出。他们可以利用这些作为未来攻击的跳板。更严重的是，他们说，这不会持续下去。波拿巴是个怪物。
He'll never honour the deal. All he thinks about is conquest and all of this. He's just buying time to prepare for the next round of fighting. And I mean, the interesting thing is Nelson's reaction to this, because you would suspect that he would be very hostile to it. Yeah. And he is very hostile to the idea of surrendering Walter that he had, You know, spent so much time blockading and everything.
他永远不会遵守协议。他想的只有征服。他只是在争取时间为下一轮战斗做准备。我是说，有趣的是纳尔逊对此的反应，因为你会怀疑他会非常敌视它。是的。他确实非常敌视放弃马耳他的想法，他花了很多时间封锁它等等。
But in general, he's actually quite positive about it. So he says, not a bad piece, all things considered. I think we talked about this in the last episode. But despite, you know, the excitement that he finds in war, he's not a warmonger. He doesn't revel in bloodshed. I think that's true. I think there's that. I think the fact that he is exhausted and, you know, he can't, he's got his eye infections
但总的来说，他对此实际上相当积极。所以他说，考虑到所有因素，这还不错。我想我们在上一集谈过这个。但尽管他在战争中找到了兴奋，但他不是一个战争贩子。他不沉溺于流血。我认为那是真的。我想有那一点。我认为他精疲力竭的事实，你知道，他不能，他有眼部感染
and he just wants to have a rest. And he wants to spend time with Emma. And the Emma issue, right? Because, of course, it's only a few weeks since he was having nightmares about her and their Prince of Wales. Yeah, and that's all calm down, I'm glad to say. It has calmed down. So, peace has come. He's allowed to go home.
他只是想休息一下。他想和艾玛在一起。还有艾玛的问题，对吧？因为，当然，距离他做关于她和威尔士亲王的噩梦才过去几周。是的，我很高兴地说，那一切都平静下来了。它已经平静下来了。所以，和平到来了。他被允许回家。
And so it is that on the 23rd of October, his carriage crosses the river Wondell, and he turns down the lane to his new house, Merton Place in Surrey. This is the house with which he and Emma are always associated. Yeah, and so today, Merton is on the northern line in. Zone 4 or 5 or whatever, very much part of Greater London. But back then, it's very leafy. The River Wondell is a river that joins the Thames. There is industrial development along it.
于是，10 月 23 日，他的马车穿过旺德尔河，他转入通往他在萨里郡的新家默顿广场的小路。这就是他和艾玛总是联系在一起的房子。是的，所以今天，默顿位于北线 4 区或 5 区，很大程度上是伦敦大伦敦的一部分。但在那时，它非常绿意盎然。旺德尔河是一条汇入泰晤士河的河流。沿岸有工业发展。
But, you know, they're a fish in the river. It's quite a bucolic scene. Yeah, it is. And Emma's been house hunting, hasn't she? She had found the house. The estate agent had said it's a terrible buy. Don't touch it. But Emma had ignored this.
但是，你知道，河里有鱼。这是一个相当田园诗般的场景。是的，它是。艾玛一直在找房子，不是吗？她找到了这所房子。房地产经纪人说这是一个糟糕的买卖。别碰它。但艾玛忽略了这一点。
And they spend, I think, the equivalent of something like 12 million pounds. on it today. Yeah, it's an expensive house and it will be very expensive to run. And to renovate and improve because that is something that they do with great gusto
他们花了，我想，相当于今天大约 1200 万英镑的钱。在上面。是的，这是一栋昂贵的房子，维护起来会非常昂贵。而且要翻新和改善，因为这是他们非常热衷的事情
because basically there are two houses that they knock them together and then they have to buy up various additional plots of land to get rid of the roads that are running through them because otherwise people will be gawping at them. They're popular with the neighbours,
因为基本上有两栋房子，他们把它们合并在一起，然后他们不得不买下各种额外的土地，以摆脱穿过它们的道路，否则人们会盯着他们看。他们很受邻居欢迎，
aren't they? There's about 800 people in Merton and most of them are farmers or work at farm labourers. They're delighted to have a celebrity, a national hero as their neighbour. And most people say that he's a nice man. He keeps himself to himself.
不是吗？默顿大约有 800 人，他们大多数是农民或农场工人。他们很高兴有一位名人、一位民族英雄作为邻居。大多数人说他是个好人。他保持低调。
You know, what's the quote? Strongly tinged with melancholy, retired and domestic in his habits. So, you know, he's not, he doesn't come the sort of lord of the manner with them. Well, he, I mean, all throughout this period, he's still haunted by his ambition to do, you know, an advertising executive retiring to Provence equivalent, which would be going to Bronte in Sicily. He has this dream of going there. But actually, he finds this country retreat. He loves it.
你知道，那句名言是什么？“带有忧郁色彩，退隐且生活习惯居家”。所以，你知道，他没有在他们面前摆出那种庄园主的架子。嗯，我是说，在整个这段时期，他仍然被他的野心所困扰，去做，你知道，一个退休到普罗旺斯的广告主管的等价物，那将是去西西里的布朗特。他有去那里的梦想。但实际上，他找到了这个乡村隐居处。他喜欢它。
So there's fishing for Sir William in the River Wondel, in the canal. Nelson obviously can't do that because he hasn't got an arm. There's a farm. He enjoys that. And he loves the house, which Emma has very tastefully decorated with loads and loads of pictures, portraits and busts of himself. Yeah, well, we'll come to this. This is controversial with his naval colleagues.
所以威廉爵士可以在旺德尔河、运河里钓鱼。纳尔逊显然不能那样做，因为他没有手臂。有一个农场。他很享受。他喜欢这所房子，艾玛用大量的图片、肖像和他的半身像非常有品位地装饰了它。是的，好吧，我们会谈到这一点。这在海军同事中是有争议的。
And he adores it, and it kind of, again, he has this kind of fantasy of what he wants it to be, and I think the fantasy comes true. So he says, we will eat plain, we'll have good wine, good fires, and a hearty welcome for our friends, but none of the great shall enter our peaceful abode. I hate them all. So this sense of, you know, he's withdrawing from his critics. He's withdrawing from all the rows he's been having with his superiors. he's been having with his superiors at the Admiralty, this is going to be where he's going
他崇拜它，它有点，再次，他有这种他想要它成为什么的幻想，我认为幻想成真了。所以他说，我们将吃得简单，我们将有好的葡萄酒、好的火炉，并为我们的朋友提供热情的欢迎，但伟人不得进入我们宁静的住所。我讨厌他们所有人。所以这种感觉，你知道，他正在从批评者中撤退。他正在从他与上司发生的所有争吵中撤退。他与海军部的上司发生过争吵，这将是他将要
to settle down. And I think it's a happy household. Nelson and Emma are very benign and generous employers. They have vast kind of domestic staff, among whom the most exotic is Fatima. Yeah, we talked about that, didn't we? Yes, who had been rescued from a slave ship of the Nile and serves Emma as her personal made and in 1802 she's baptised at Merton Church and also they're all the kind of the farmhands and there are friends who come and they have lots of children and Nelson adores children so again
安顿下来的地方。我认为这是一个幸福的家庭。纳尔逊和艾玛是非常温和慷慨的雇主。他们有大量的家政人员，其中最异国情调的是法蒂玛。是的，我们谈过那个，不是吗？是的，她是从尼罗河的一艘奴隶船上被救出来的，作为艾玛的私人女仆服务，1802 年她在默顿教堂受洗，还有各种农场工人，还有朋友们来，他们有很多孩子，纳尔逊崇拜孩子，所以再次
this makes him happy but Dominant there are complications as well aren't there it's not absolute paradise yeah now listeners can always rely on you Tom to present the most the sunniest possible portrait of the Nelson Minaj but they can also rely on me to be this shower of yes the serpent in the garden thanks so first First of all, there's money. There's a big money issue. So Nelson, you may recall, was only made a baron by George III and not a Viscount because he wasn't rich enough.
这让他快乐，但多米尼克，也有复杂的情况，不是吗？这不是绝对的天堂。是的，现在听众总是可以指望你汤姆来呈现关于纳尔逊三人组最阳光的画像，但他们也可以指望我成为这个淋浴的，是的，花园里的毒蛇。谢谢，所以首先，有钱的问题。有一个巨大的金钱问题。所以纳尔逊，你可能记得，乔治三世只封他为男爵，而不是子爵，因为他不够富有。
George the 3rd said he won't be able to sustain a Viscount's lifestyle. George the third was not wrong. So merely to raise the deposit for this 12 million pound house, he has had to sell lots of stock and he's had to take out the diamonds from the various jewels that had been given to him as sort of presents from foreign rulers and replace them with paste. So there's a slight sense of being hard done by, I think, when he moves in. He shouldn't have had to do this because the government should have looked after him. And I think that's what's feeding into his, you know, we're not going to have the great and the good come and stay with us because they're screwing me out of my diamonds and not giving me the money I deserve.
乔治三世说他无法维持子爵的生活方式。乔治三世没有错。所以仅仅为了筹集这栋 1200 万英镑房子的押金，他不得不卖掉大量的股票，他不得不从外国统治者作为礼物送给他的各种珠宝中取出钻石，并用玻璃制品代替。所以当他搬进去时，有一种被亏待的感觉，我想。他不应该这样做，因为政府应该照顾他。我认为这就是导致他的，你知道，我们不会让大人物和好人来和我们住在一起，因为他们正在从我的钻石中榨取我，而不给我应得的钱。
I'm sorry to say that I think the Hamilton's do rather feed this, as we shall see. In fact, a theme of the next few years is anxiety about money. So to give people a sense, in the money terms of the day, Nelson made about £4,000 a year. But of that, he has to give £1,800 to Fanny as her allowance. This is basically, you know, the financial deal he's offered her to go away. At the same time, Merton is very expensive to run. So he spends more than £3,000 on food and wine alone at Merton. The upside is that Sir William Hamilton has said, well, I will pay half.
我很抱歉地说，我认为汉密尔顿一家确实助长了这一点，正如我们将要看到的。事实上，未来几年的一个主题是对金钱的焦虑。所以给人们一个概念，在当时的货币条件下，纳尔逊每年赚大约 4000 英镑。但其中，他必须给范妮 1800 英镑作为她的津贴。这基本上是，你知道，他提供给她的让她离开的经济协议。与此同时，默顿的运营成本非常高。所以他仅在默顿的食物和葡萄酒上就花费了超过 3000 英镑。好处是威廉·汉密尔顿爵士说，好吧，我会付一半。
That brings us to the Sir William Hamilton issue. There's a problem there, isn't there? Because he's kind of, you know, he's been dismissed from his post in Naples and come back slightly under a cloud and hasn't been given a pension. And so I think actually quite a lot of the Nelson worrying about the Emma going after the Prince of Wales stuff, I think Emma basically is approaching the Prince of Wales to try and get William a pension and it doesn't work. Completely. So when Nelson says, I mean, he effectively says, Sir William is pimping you out, that is what is happening. I mean, that is exactly Sir William Hamilton's plan, I think. So Sir William Hamilton is now 71. He's visibly in decline. He spends a lot of time at the Royal Society and other kind of learned societies in London. He loves his fishing. He does. So he comes back to the house and fishes. But he has, for form's sake, he has to maintain a house in Piccadilly. Because the government basically haven't given him a decent pension. he's running out of money as well. Now, what exacerbates all this? It's the fact he has a wife who loves spending money.
这把我们带到了威廉·汉密尔顿爵士的问题。那里有一个问题，不是吗？因为他有点，你知道，他被解除了在拿波里的职务，回来时有点名声受损，而且没有得到养老金。所以我认为实际上纳尔逊担心艾玛追求威尔士亲王的事情，我想艾玛基本上是在接近威尔士亲王试图为威廉争取养老金，但这没有奏效。完全没有。所以当纳尔逊说，我是说，他实际上说，威廉爵士在把你当皮条客，这就是正在发生的事情。我是说，我认为那正是威廉·汉密尔顿爵士的计划。所以威廉·汉密尔顿爵士现在 71 岁了。他明显在衰退。他花了很多时间在伦敦的皇家学会和其他学术团体。他喜欢钓鱼。他确实喜欢。所以他回到房子里钓鱼。但他有，为了形式，他必须在皮卡迪利维持一所房子。因为政府基本上没有给他一份体面的养老金。他的钱也快用完了。现在，是什么加剧了这一切？事实是他有一个喜欢花钱的妻子。
I guess in the way that someone who has had no money, who knows what it is to live on the streets and have not a penny, it's difficult, I guess, if you've had that upbringing to behave abstemiously. Well, if your identity, I suppose, and your sense of self-worth, I mean, it's not an unfamiliar story. if your self-worth and identity are based on spectacle, on show, on fashion, on all of those kinds of things. I mean, she's always running up massive debts. So in today's money, in 1802 alone, she spent more than a quarter of a million pounds on jewelry, for example.
我猜就像一个没有钱的人，知道在街上生活、一分钱都没有是什么感觉，我猜如果你有那样的成长经历，要表现得节俭是很困难的。嗯，如果你的身份，我假设，以及你的自我价值感，我是说，这不是一个不熟悉的故事。如果你的自我价值和身份是基于奇观、展示、时尚、所有这些事情。我是说，她总是背负巨额债务。所以按今天的货币计算，仅在 1802 年，她就在珠宝上花费了超过 25 万英镑。
And the other thing she has done, which, of course, Fanny didn't do enough, which is one of the things that did for her, was, as you said, she's basically turned the house into a Nelson shrine. So there's an awful lot of Nelson merch at this point, and a lot of it has been bought by Emma. Yeah. And so wherever you look in the house, there are Prince of Nelson, his battles, the dinner service, the tea service, the coffee service, have all been engraved to celebrate his battles. I think she's also buying memorabilia associated with herself as well. She is indeed, yeah. There are quite a lot of prints and paintings of Emma.
她做的另一件事，当然，范妮做得不够，这是导致她失败的事情之一，正如你所说，她基本上把房子变成了一个纳尔逊神殿。所以此时有很多纳尔逊的周边商品，其中很多是艾玛买的。是的。所以无论你在房子里看哪里，都有纳尔逊的王子，他的战斗，餐具、茶具、咖啡具，都刻上了庆祝他战斗的图案。我想她也在买与她自己相关的纪念品。她确实是，是的。有很多艾玛的版画和画作。
So there's a slightly, I hope some of our American listeners will not be offended when I say, it's a slightly Mara Lago scene. And even at the time, some visitors are absolutely appalled by it. So there's a mate of Nelson's called Lord Minto, who quoted before. Yeah, we met him in Vienna, didn't we, where he was comparing Emma to a barmaid. He had first met Nelson in Corsica in the 1790s. When he comes to Merton Place, he's horrified by it. And it's interesting, he doesn't just blame Emma.
所以有一点，我希望我们的一些美国听众在我说的时候不会被冒犯，这是一个稍微有点海湖庄园（Mara Lago）的场景。即使在当时，一些访客也对此感到非常震惊。所以有一个纳尔逊的朋友叫明托勋爵，之前引用过。是的，我们在维也纳见过他，不是吗？在那里他把艾玛比作酒吧女招待。他是在 18 世纪 90 年代在科西嘉岛第一次见到纳尔逊的。当他来到默顿广场时，他被吓坏了。有趣的是，他不仅责怪艾玛。
He does blame her, but he blames Nelson as well. The whole establishment and way of life is such as to make me angry as well as melancholy. She's in high looks, but more immense than ever. She goes on cramming Nelson with trowfuls of flattery, which she goes on taking as quietly as a child does pap. The love she makes to him is not only ridiculous, but disgusting. Not only the rooms, but the whole house, staircase and all, are covered with nothing but pictures of her and him of all sizes and sorts, an excessive vanity which counteracts
他确实责怪她，但也责怪纳尔逊。整个建制和生活方式让人既生气又忧郁。她看起来很漂亮，但比以往任何时候都更巨大。她继续用大量的奉承来填塞纳尔逊，他像孩子吃糊状食物一样安静地接受。她对他表现出的爱不仅荒谬，而且令人作呕。不仅是房间，整个房子，楼梯和所有地方，都覆盖着各种大小和种类的她和他的照片，一种抵消了
its own purpose. If it was Lady Hamilton's house, there might be a pretense for it, to make his own a mere looking glass to view himself all day his bad taste. I mean, that's the inimitable voice of the British visitor to an American house, isn't it? Well, it's the inimitable voice of the British upper classes towards, you know, new money, basically. Yes, it is. Exactly. I mean, that's what it is. And also he comments, and I can believe this, that Nelson, you know, away from a theatre of war is actually quite boring. Yeah. Because he only talks about himself and his battles, I imagine. It's a bit like Napoleon on, when in exile on San Helena. You know, Napoleon just talked about his own battles and how he'd been hard done by. And I think Nelson
其自身目的的过度虚荣。如果这是汉密尔顿夫人的房子，可能还有借口，让自己的房子成为一面整天审视自己的镜子，品味太差。我是说，那是英国访客对美国房子的那种不可模仿的声音，不是吗？嗯，这是英国上层阶级对，你知道，新钱，基本上那种不可模仿的声音。是的，它是。正是如此。而且他还评论说，我相信这一点，纳尔逊，远离战争剧场，实际上相当无聊。是的。因为我想他只谈论他自己和他的战斗。这有点像拿破仑在圣赫勒拿岛流亡时。你知道，拿破仑只是谈论他自己的战斗以及他如何被亏待。我认为纳尔逊
is very similar. Yeah. And I think also maybe that that trend in Nelson is shown up by the fact that Sir William, of course, has lots of, you know, radical friends, intellectual friends, scholarly friends. They're all coming and talking about pots and vases and classical literature and stuff like that. And I can imagine that Nelson, in that company, you know, he wouldn't have much to contribute and would shrink into his shell. And actually, some of Nelson's friends pointedly do not visit him at his house. So the most obvious is Cuthbert Collingwood, who famously appears at Trafalgar. And his great friend from his kind of early years of service. Yeah. Roger Knight points out in his book, you know, when Collingwood went to visit friends nearby,
非常相似。是的。而且我认为纳尔逊的那种趋势可能被威廉爵士的事实所衬托，当然，他有很多，你知道，激进的朋友、知识分子朋友、学术朋友。他们都来谈论罐子、花瓶和古典文学之类的东西。我可以想象纳尔逊在那种公司里，你知道，他不会有什么贡献，会缩进他的壳里。实际上，纳尔逊的一些朋友明确表示不去他的房子拜访他。所以最明显的是卡斯伯特·科林伍德，他在特拉法加战役中很有名。他从他早年服役开始就是他的好朋友。是的。罗杰·奈特在他的书中指出，你知道，当科林伍德去拜访附近的朋友时，
he very pointedly didn't go to visit Nelson and Merton, which you kind of think he should have done. And probably that's because he finds the setup. It's just not to his taste. It's basically a Nelson shrine with Emma kind of talking 19 to the dozen. Of course, the terror is that she might start doing some other attitudes, Tom, and no one wants that. I think in Naples, Emma was a star. She was the friend of Queens and of aristocrats. And that simply hasn't happened in Britain because she offends, I think, both the taste and the social mores of the upper classes. And I think that's a real problem for Emma, but also therefore for Nelson, and particularly because they've made such a scandal of their relationship.
他非常明确地没有去拜访默顿的纳尔逊，你有点认为他应该这样做。可能那是因为他觉得这种设置。这根本不符合他的口味。它基本上是一个纳尔逊神殿，艾玛在喋喋不休。当然，恐怖的是她可能会开始做一些其他的姿态，汤姆，没有人想要那个。我认为在拿波里，艾玛是一位明星。她是女王和贵族的朋友。而在英国这根本没有发生，因为她冒犯了，我认为，上层阶级的品味和社会习俗。我认为这对艾玛来说是一个真正的问题，因此对纳尔逊也是，特别是因为他们把他们的关系搞成了丑闻。
Yeah. And because they've made a scandal of the relationship, she and Sir William are shunned by their very high society. They are not welcome at court. They're being mocked all the time in cartoons. And I think Dominic, it's a reminder that obviously Nelson has sacrificed things for their relationship. You know, he's sacrificed his marriage. But Emma has sacrificed things as well.
是的。而且因为他们把这段关系搞成了丑闻，她和威廉爵士被他们的上流社会所回避。他们不受宫廷欢迎。他们一直被漫画嘲笑。我认为多米尼克，这是一个提醒，显然纳尔逊为他们的关系牺牲了东西。你知道，他牺牲了他的婚姻。但艾玛也牺牲了东西。
I think she would have socially been much better off if she had not embarked on the affair with Nelson. Yeah, I think that's probably fair. People might have been prepared to cut her some slack as a lady Hamilton who is not committing an adulterous affair. I think she'd have always found it difficult, wouldn't she, back in London? I think she'd have always, there would always have been people who looked down their noses at her. But she might have been cut more slack, I think. A little bit, yeah. But she makes it worse.
我认为如果她没有开始与纳尔逊的恋情，她在社交上会好得多。是的，我认为这可能是公平的。人们可能准备对作为汉密尔顿夫人的她网开一面，如果她没有进行通奸的话。我想她总是会觉得困难，不是吗，回到伦敦？我想她总是会，总会有看不起她的人。但我想她可能会被网开一面。一点点，是的。但她让情况变得更糟。
She's very bad at her own PR. So whenever she does go out in London, she says to people very loudly, Sir William has been so hard done by, he's such a brilliant man. He should be in the palace at Lambeth. Nelson should be a Duke greater than Marlborough. And so people say, God, these Hamilton's that, ghastly people. Just massive sponges and winges. Here's Sir William said to the government, I've run out of money.
她非常不擅长自己的公关。所以每当她在伦敦外出时，她都会很大声地对人们说，威廉爵士被亏待得太厉害了，他是一个如此聪明的人。他应该在兰贝斯的宫殿里。纳尔逊应该是一个比马尔伯勒更大的公爵。所以人们说，上帝，这些汉密尔顿一家，可怕的人。只是巨大的海绵和抱怨者。这是威廉爵士对政府说，我的钱用完了。
Can you settle my debts, please? And the government said, no, sell your art collection. Why should we settle your debts? And I think what happens is that they in this period, they do feed a trait that Nelson already had, which is this kind of neediness and this self-pity. You know, this is one of it, I think one of his least attractive traits, that he's always moaning, moaning at his superiors, saying that he's not being taken seriously enough, that he should have better reward, sort of this kind of thing.
你能帮我解决债务吗？政府说，不，卖掉你的艺术收藏。我们为什么要解决你的债务？我认为发生的事情是，他们在这段时间里，确实助长了纳尔逊已经拥有的一个特质，那就是这种需求感和这种自怜。你知道，这是其中之一，我认为他最不吸引人的特质之一，他总是抱怨，向他的上司抱怨，说他没有被足够认真地对待，他应该得到更好的奖励，这种事情。
It's a bit like, do you remember when it wasn't David Beckham? There was a leaked message. Yes, he wanted a knighthood. He wanted a knighthood. And he was absolutely furious. What more do I have to do? But to be fair to him, he got it in the end. He did.
这有点像，你还记得大卫·贝克汉姆吗？有一条泄露的信息。是的，他想要一个爵士头衔。他想要一个爵士头衔。他非常愤怒。我还需要做什么？但公平地说，他最终得到了它。他确实得到了。
He did. So I think if you nag hard enough, maybe you get there. That's the lesson. There's a lesson for you there, Tom. So some listeners may well say, well, say, well, this is all just ghasty snobbery from the establishment. You know, M. Poor old Emma, poor old Nelson. Well, I mean, I think it is. Well, I think there's an element of truth that it is snobbery, but, you know, they're not saints.
他确实做到了。所以我认为如果你唠叨得够多，也许就能达到目的。这就是教训。汤姆，这对你来说也是个教训。所以有些听众可能会说，好吧，好吧，这不过是建制派那种令人作呕的势利眼罢了。你知道，M。可怜的艾玛，可怜的纳尔逊。嗯，我的意思是，我认为确实如此。嗯，我认为势利眼确实是其中一部分原因，但是，你知道，他们也不是圣人。
Even Nelson's not a saint, Tom, I hate to break it to you. And Emma does, she does let herself down in this regard. She is waging a long campaign against Fanny still, and she is writing to Nelson's relatives and saying to them, Fanny is a wicked, bad, artful woman with a cold heart and infamous soul and all of this kind. I mean, this shows her at her worst, I think. She also has an animus, doesn't she, a little bit against Edmund, Edmund Nelson, who she knows doesn't approve of her because she says to the relatives, Edmund is just Fanny's
汤姆，即使是纳尔逊也不是圣人，我不想让你失望。艾玛确实在这方面让自己丢了脸。她仍在对范妮进行长期的攻击，她写信给纳尔逊的亲戚，对他们说范妮是一个邪恶、糟糕、狡诈的女人，心肠冷酷，灵魂卑劣，诸如此类。我的意思是，我认为这展现了她最糟糕的一面。她对埃德蒙，也就是埃德蒙·纳尔逊，也有一种敌意，不是吗？她知道埃德蒙不赞成她的所作所为，因为她对亲戚们说，埃德蒙只是范妮的
dupe. Edmund is Fanny's puppet and all this kind of thing. Now, actually, we know Edmund was incredibly close to Fanny. He saw her as the second daughter. He adored her. And when Nelson kicked her out, Edmund said to her, I would happily come and live with you in Bath. And actually Fanny said no, because she said, I don't want to drive Horatio against you. this will drive a wedge between you and her ratio, which is, you know, poor old Fanny. I think Fanny's, I think Fanny's brilliant, but quite boring. Well, yeah, but maybe I like a boring person. Yeah.
傀儡。埃德蒙是范妮的玩偶，诸如此类。然而，实际上我们知道埃德蒙和范妮非常亲近。他把她看作第二个女儿。他非常宠爱她。当纳尔逊把她赶走时，埃德蒙对她说，我愿意很高兴地和你一起住在巴斯。实际上范妮拒绝了，因为她说，我不想让你和霍拉蒂奥反目。这会在你和霍拉蒂奥之间造成隔阂，你知道的，可怜的范妮。我认为范妮很出色，但相当无聊。嗯，是的，但也许我喜欢无聊的人。是的。
You know, I'm more tolerant than you are, Tom. I mean, that's, everyone always says that about me. Such a tolerance. They do. Such a tolerance and kind person. So, Fanny makes one last attempt to win Nelson back in Christmas 1801, another heart-rending letter. do my dear husband let us live together i assure you i have but one wish in the world to please you let everything be buried in oblivion it will pass away like a dream and tom how does nelson reply to this
你知道，我比你更宽容，汤姆。我的意思是，每个人总是这样评价我。真是宽容。他们确实这么说。真是个宽容又善良的人。所以，范妮在1801年圣诞节做了最后一次挽回纳尔逊的尝试，又是一封令人心碎的信。我亲爱的丈夫，让我们住在一起吧，我向你保证，我这辈子只有一个愿望，那就是让你高兴。让一切都随风而去吧，它会像梦一样消逝。汤姆，纳尔逊是怎么回复的？
he completely ignores it um and the comment on the letter is opened by mistake by lord nelson but not red that's harsh isn't it so a few months after that edmund finally died he died in bath he had his funeral in burnham thorpe everybody all the other nelson's went but horatio nelson did not go. He said he was ill. Roger Knight in his biography says, come on, you know, we all know what's going on here. Basically, Nelson feels really guilty and embarrassed about his father and their relationship and how the turn his private life has made. Yeah, but also the classic, you know, you don't want to take your new partner. You know, she doesn't want to go. Yeah. Yeah. So he doesn't go. Edmund's death is pretty bad news for Fanny, actually, because the rest of the family then
他完全无视了它，嗯，这封信被纳尔逊勋爵误拆了，但没有读。这很刻薄，不是吗？所以在那几个月后，埃德蒙终于去世了，他在巴斯去世。他的葬礼在伯纳姆索普举行，所有其他的纳尔逊家族成员都去了，但霍拉蒂奥·纳尔逊没有去。他说他病了。罗杰·奈特在传记中说，得了吧，你知道，我们都知道发生了什么。基本上，纳尔逊对他的父亲、他们的关系以及他私生活的转变感到非常内疚和尴尬。是的，但这也是经典的情况，你知道，你不想带你的新伴侣去。你知道，她不想去。是的。是的。所以他没去。埃德蒙的去世对范妮来说其实是个坏消息，因为家族的其他成员随后
cut her off. Some of Nelson's fellow officers, though, did keep in touch with her, didn't they? So Thomas Hardy, who in many ways is actually quite an unattractive man with his enthusiasm for the lash, he made a great effort to keep in touch with Fannie. He used to have breakfast with her, and there's a letter he writes to his brother and said, I've just had breakfast with Fanny Nelson. She's one of the best women in the world, he said. I praise. And I think it's interesting that in the wake of all this, you can tell that Nelson is feeling bad about himself because he then arranges to go on a kind of publicity tour in which loads of people will turn out and give him hussars and say how brilliant he is.
切断了与她的联系。不过，纳尔逊的一些军官同事确实和她保持着联系，不是吗？所以托马斯·哈迪，他在很多方面其实是一个相当令人反感的人，因为他热衷于鞭刑，但他确实努力与范妮保持联系。他过去常和她一起吃早餐，他写给兄弟的一封信中说，我刚和范妮·纳尔逊吃过早餐。她是世界上最好的女人之一，他说。我赞美。而且我认为有趣的是，在这一切之后，你可以看出纳尔逊对自己感觉很不好，因为他随后安排了一次宣传巡游，届时会有很多人出来为他欢呼，说他有多么出色。
So he goes in the summer of 1802. He and the Hamilton's go on a trip to Wales. And actually, it's prompted by a gravel who is Emma's old. She'd been mistress to him eons before. And he wants to develop a port in Wales, so that's the ostensible reason that they go. But actually, it's like a kind of rock star on tour. And I think that it plays a crucial role in establishing Nelson as a genuinely national hero, because no one has ever done this before. I mean, maybe royals have on occasion, but it is like a kind of royal progress. He's the first commoner to do this. And it has this, you know, it kind of seals the relationship between him and the people of Britain, I think. Yeah. I think there's a slight melancholy to Nelson, though. Do you not have this?
所以他在1802年夏天去了。他和汉密尔顿一家去威尔士旅行。实际上，这是由格雷维尔促成的，他是艾玛的老相好。很久以前她曾是他的情妇。他想在威尔士开发一个港口，所以这是他们去的表面原因。但实际上，这就像摇滚明星巡演一样。我认为这在确立纳尔逊作为真正的民族英雄方面发挥了关键作用，因为以前没有人这样做过。我的意思是，也许皇室成员偶尔会这样做，但这就像一种皇室巡游。他是第一个这样做的平民。我认为这巩固了他与英国人民之间的关系。是的。不过，我觉得纳尔逊身上有一丝忧郁。你没有这种感觉吗？
Of course. Yeah. These years, when people went to dinner, they would say, you know, Emma does all the talking and he sits there very quietly, sort of staring out of the window. And he was always wearing black. I mean, that's not, this is in mourning. It's just because he often, he dressed in a very conservative style, ironically, given who he's living with. Well, I think, actually, that when he comes back to Merton, I think he is happy with Emma there.
当然。是的。这些年，当人们去吃晚饭时，他们会说，你知道，艾玛一直在说话，而他静静地坐在那里，盯着窗外。他总是穿着黑色衣服。我的意思是，这不是，这是在哀悼。这只是因为他经常穿一种非常保守的风格，讽刺的是，考虑到他正和谁住在一起。嗯，我认为，实际上，当他回到默顿后，我认为他在那里和艾玛在一起很幸福。
And I think particularly after what happens in April 1803, which, she's when Sir William Hamilton dies. I mean, Emma mourns him. Nelson mourns him. He dies in Emma's arms. Nelson is holding his hands. And Emma's terribly upset about it, partly emotionally, but partly also because it unleashes additional money problems, because she'd been hoping to be left lots of money in his will. But actually, Hamilton has left his estates to a relative, and she just gets this income of £700 a year. And I think that's because Hamilton, is assuming that Nelson will be able to look after her. So it's a problem.
而且我认为特别是在1803年4月发生的事情之后，也就是威廉·汉密尔顿爵士去世的时候。我的意思是，艾玛哀悼他。纳尔逊哀悼他。他在艾玛的怀里去世。纳尔逊握着他的手。艾玛对此非常难过，部分是情感上的，但部分也是因为它引发了额外的金钱问题，因为她一直希望在他的遗嘱中留下很多钱。但实际上，汉密尔顿把他的遗产留给了一个亲戚，她只得到了每年700英镑的收入。我认为这是因为汉密尔顿假设纳尔逊能够照顾她。所以这是一个问题。
And Hardy, who doesn't like her at all, kind of basically gloats over it, how her leadership will manage to live with the hero of the Nile now. I'm at a lost to know, at least in an honorable way. And it's very, very Jane Austen again, the sense in which it's never just about your personal emotions. It's always about your income. However, money problems aside, it does now mean that essentially Emma and Nelson can live together as a married couple in all but name. And I think that this makes both of them as happy as either of them have ever been in the course of their lives.
而根本不喜欢她的哈迪，基本上是在幸灾乐祸，想知道她现在将如何与尼罗河英雄生活在一起。我不知道，至少以一种体面的方式。这又非常、非常像简·奥斯汀，那种从来不仅仅关乎个人情感，总是关乎收入的感觉。然而，撇开金钱问题不谈，这确实意味着艾玛和纳尔逊现在基本上可以以夫妻名义生活在一起了。我认为这让他们俩都达到了各自一生中最幸福的状态。
And for both of them, there is a kind of novelty in being a happily married, inverted commas, domestic couple. Because Andrew Lambert in his biography quotes this amazing fact, which I'd know. never kind of, I'd never have thought of before. He says that when Nelson returned ashore from abroad in October 1801, it was the first time that he had ever slept in his own house. He'd never done that before. Yeah, because they'd be living with his father or being in hotels or whatever. Or on ships, most of the time. So a real novelty. And for Emma to live with with Nelson, I mean, it's the first time she is living with a man who she hasn't been pimped to. So I think, I think there is, you know, there is real happiness there. However,
对他们俩来说，成为一对幸福的、加引号的、家庭式的伴侣有一种新鲜感。因为安德鲁·兰伯特在传记中引用了这个惊人的事实，我以前从未想到过。他说，当纳尔逊在1801年10月从国外回到岸上时，这是他第一次睡在自己的房子里。他以前从未这样做过。是的，因为他们要么和他父亲住在一起，要么住在酒店里，或者其他什么地方。或者大部分时间都在船上。所以这是一种真正的新鲜感。对于艾玛来说，和纳尔逊住在一起，我的意思是，这是她第一次和一个没有把她当作皮条客交易对象的男人生活在一起。所以我认为，我认为那里确实有真正的幸福。然而，
Dominic, the problem is that even when the sun is shining, there are always clouds massing in the background to block out the rays. What's really frightening is if those clouds turn out to be the storm clouds at war. And you know what? Over the winter of 1802, 1803, there have been growing fears that the peace of Amia, as its critics claimed, was just a sham after all. So both Britain and France, have basically spent the piece re-arming. The French in particular spending a lot of money on their Navy. Now, Napoleon has shown no sign of curbing his appetite for conquest. In September 1802, he annexed Piedmont, and he declared himself the president of the Sassalpine Republic in northern Italy, and then he sent troops to intervene in Switzerland. So it's clear that he is
多米尼克，问题在于即使阳光明媚，背景中也总有乌云聚集，遮挡住光芒。真正可怕的是，如果那些乌云变成了战争的暴风雨。你知道吗？在1802年到1803年的冬天，人们越来越担心亚眠和约，正如批评者所言，毕竟只是一个骗局。所以英国和法国基本上都把和平时期花在了重新武装上。法国人尤其在海军上花费了大量资金。现在，拿破仑没有表现出任何抑制征服欲望的迹象。1802年9月，他吞并了皮埃蒙特，并宣布自己为意大利北部的萨尔平共和国总统，然后他派兵干预瑞士。所以很明显，他正在
gearing up for another go. I suppose, just to put it in the balance, the British have not given up Malta. Yeah, but would you, Tom, would you give up Malta in the face of such a threat? No, I wouldn't. But just setting that in the balance. Yes, that's fair. For our French listener, we'll appreciate that. So by the turn of 1803, the mood in Britain feels very, you know, summer of 1939.
为下一次行动做准备。我想，权衡一下，英国人还没有放弃马耳他。是的，但是汤姆，面对这样的威胁，你会放弃马耳他吗？不，我不会。但只是权衡一下。是的，这很公平。我们的法国听众会理解这一点。所以到了1803年之交，英国的气氛感觉非常像1939年的夏天。
We've given bone apart every chance to prove himself a man of peace, but he can't be trusted. And you quoted Andrew Lambert, great naval historian earlier, Lambert, who is very much a Bonaparte skeptic, if not a Bonaparte phob. He's actually got a book out just now on how Britain organizes things after Napoleon's defeat to ensure that a Bonaparte will never arise again. Right. Well, he says basically Bonaparte's long-term aims were such that no British government could ever have accepted them.
我们给了波拿巴每一个证明自己是和平之人的机会，但他不可信。你刚才引用了伟大的海军历史学家安德鲁·兰伯特的话，兰伯特非常怀疑波拿巴，甚至可以说是波拿巴恐惧症患者。他最近刚出了一本书，关于英国如何在拿破仑战败后组织事务，以确保波拿巴永远不会再出现。对。好吧，他基本上说波拿巴的长期目标是任何英国政府都无法接受的。
He wanted to reduce his neighbours to client states. His long-term aims were southern Italy, Greece, Egypt and so on. There could be no lasting peace with the regime that did not accept the rules of the state system, and this would require a total war. So on the 10th of May, 1803, Britain's ambassador, Addington's ambassador in Paris, hands over an ultimatum. They want the French to pull out of Holland and Switzerland, and they want Britain particularly to keep this naval base in Malta. They get no reply, and a week later, Britain declares war.
他想把邻国变成附庸国。他的长期目标是意大利南部、希腊、埃及等等。与一个不接受国家体系规则的政权不可能有持久的和平，这将需要一场全面战争。因此，1803年5月10日，英国驻巴黎大使，也就是阿丁顿的大使，递交了一份最后通牒。他们要求法国撤出荷兰和瑞士，他们特别要求英国保留马耳他的这个海军基地。他们没有得到答复，一周后，英国对法国宣战。
on France. And everybody knows that this will be. It's not going to be like the seven years war. Beating France will be a total national mobilization. The Napoleon Wars have been eclipsed, I think, in our popular imagination by the World Wars as an existential challenge. But an existential challenge is exactly what they are. To give you a flavor, two months into the war, William Pitt, who's been ill, comes back to the comments. And he gives an incredible speech to kind of stiffen the nerves of his old colleagues. Chachillian speech. And he says,
每个人都知道这将是。这不会像七年战争那样。击败法国将是一场全面的国家动员。我认为拿破仑战争在我们的流行想象中已经被世界大战作为一种生存挑战所掩盖。但生存挑战正是它们的本质。给你一个概念，战争开始两个月后，一直生病的威廉·皮特回到了下议院。他发表了一场令人难以置信的演讲，旨在增强他老同事们的神经。丘吉尔式的演讲。他说，
This is not just another war. It's a war against a dictator who's broken all his promises and will stop at nothing. We are called to struggle for the destiny, not of this country alone, but of the civilized world.
这不仅仅是另一场战争。这是一场针对一个打破了所有承诺且不择手段的独裁者的战争。我们被召唤去为命运而奋斗，不仅是为了这个国家，也是为了文明世界。
This is a war for our property. It is for our liberty. It is for our independence, nay, for our existence as a nation. It is for our character. It is for our very name as Englishman. It is for everything dear and valuable to man on this.
这是一场为了我们的财产而战的战争。这是为了我们的自由。这是为了我们的独立，不，是为了我们作为一个国家的生存。这是为了我们的品格。这是为了我们作为英国人的名声。这是为了人类在这一边所珍视和有价值的一切。
side of the grave. And I think that just as Churchill was summoning Britain in 1940 to a total war, Pitt is doing the same. And it's a great mustering of finance and manpower. And the focus of that effort is the Royal Navy. And the maintaining of the Royal Navy in this war is, I think, probably the greatest project undertaken by any state in history up until that point. And it is a precursor of the total wars of the 20th century. It is a massive, massive moment. And of all the Royal Navy's weapons, I suppose two stand out. So one of them we're very familiar with, Nelson himself. He's given his orders on the day war breaks out, take command of the Mediterranean fleet, proceed to Malta, and then head to Toulon, ideally to destroy the French
坟墓的一侧。我认为，正如丘吉尔在1940年号召英国进行全面战争一样，皮特也在做同样的事情。这是一次伟大的财政和人力动员。而这一努力的焦点是皇家海军。我认为，在这场战争中维持皇家海军可能是历史上任何国家在那之前所承担的最伟大的工程。它是20世纪全面战争的前奏。这是一个巨大、巨大的时刻。在皇家海军的所有武器中，我想有两个脱颖而出。所以其中一个我们非常熟悉，纳尔逊本人。他在战争爆发当天接到命令，接管地中海舰队，前往马耳他，然后前往土伦，理想情况下是摧毁法国
fleet. And that same day, the 18th of May, he arrives in Portsmouth to take control of the other great weapon. And this is his new flagship, one of the greatest ships that Britain has ever built. She is almost 50 years old, but she's been in the dockyards for repairs for three years. She's a first-rate ship of the line with three decks, 850 sailors and 104 guns, the supreme fighting machine, the great weapon to defy the dictator. And her name, of course, Tom. is the victory. Well, do you know, Dominic, I feel so overwhelmed by patriotism that I need to have a break. I'm sure everyone else does as well.
舰队。同一天，5月18日，他抵达朴茨茅斯，接管了另一个伟大的武器。这就是他的新旗舰，英国建造过的最伟大的船只之一。她已经有近50年的历史了，但在船坞里修理了三年。她是一艘拥三层甲板、850名水手和104门火炮的一级战列舰，是至高无上的战斗机器，是反抗独裁者的伟大武器。当然，她的名字，汤姆，是胜利号。嗯，你知道，多米尼克，我感到被爱国主义淹没了，我需要休息一下。我相信其他人也一样。
So let's do that. And when we come back, the war begins. This episode is brought to you by Uber. Now, do you know that feeling when someone shows up for you when you need it most? We all need that sometimes. And Uber knows it. Uber isn't just a ride or a meal delivered. it's showing up no matter what.
所以我们休息一下。当我们回来时，战争就开始了。本集由优步赞助。现在，你知道当有人在你最需要的时候出现的那种感觉吗？我们有时都需要那样。优步知道这一点。优步不仅仅是乘车或送餐，它是在无论发生什么情况下都会出现。
Like for your long distance friends, bringing soup when they're sick, sending flowers when they're down. When it really matters, whatever it is, you show up. Where there's a will, we're on our way. Uber, on our way. Download the app today. With Amex Platinum, access to exclusive Amex pre-sale tickets can score you a spot trackside, so being a fan for life turns into the trip of a lifetime.
就像为你远方的朋友，在他们生病时送去汤，在他们情绪低落时送去鲜花。当它真正重要时，无论是什么，你都会出现。有志者事竟成，我们在路上。优步，在路上。立即下载应用程序。使用美国运通白金卡，获得独家美国运通预售门票，可以让你在赛道边占据一席之地，让成为终身粉丝变成一生难忘的旅程。
The Powerful Backing of Amex. Pre-sale tickets for future events subject to availability and vary by race. Terms and conditions apply. Learn more at amex.ca.ca. slash Yanex. This episode is brought to you by Peloton. A new era of fitness is here.
美国运通的强大支持。未来活动的预售门票视供应情况而定，并因比赛而异。条款和条件适用。在 amex.ca.ca/Yanex 了解更多信息。本集由 Peloton 赞助。健身的新时代已经到来。
Introducing the new Peloton Cross Training Tread Plus, powered by Peloton IQ. Built for breakthroughs with personalized workout plans, real-time insights, and endless ways to move. Lift with confidence. While Peloton IQ counts reps, corrects form, and tracks your progress.
隆重推出全新的 Peloton 交叉训练跑步机 Plus，由 Peloton IQ 提供支持。专为突破而生，提供个性化的锻炼计划、实时见解和无限的运动方式。自信地举重。当 Peloton IQ 计算次数、纠正姿势并跟踪你的进度时。
Let yourself run, lift, flow, and go. Explore the new Peloton Cross-Training Treadplus at OnePeloton.C.A. Hello, welcome back to the rest is history and to Total War, Napoleonic style. So we're in the late summer of 1803. Nelson has arrived in Malta. He's taken over as commander-in-chief in the Mediterranean, and he has established himself in command of a block. arcade outside the French base at Toulon.
让自己奔跑、举重、流动和前进。在 OnePeloton.C.A 探索全新的 Peloton 交叉训练跑步机 Plus。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》，回到拿破仑式的全面战争。所以我们现在是1803年的夏末。纳尔逊已经抵达马耳他。他已经接任地中海总司令，并确立了自己在土伦法国基地外的封锁指挥权。
And Dominic, I'm guessing this is a very sweet moment for him because he'd been acting Commander-in-Chief before, but then he'd been replaced by Lord Keith. And the fact that the Admiralty are happy to give him command of the Mediterranean theatre reflects the rise in his reputation, the degree of trust that government is now prepared to place in him. Yeah, I think that's right. I think he's completely redeemed himself from the low point
多米尼克，我猜这对他是非常甜蜜的时刻，因为他之前曾担任代理总司令，但后来被基思勋爵取代了。海军部乐意让他指挥地中海战区的事实反映了他声誉的提升，以及政府现在准备给予他的信任程度。是的，我认为是对的。我认为他已经完全从几年前的低谷中自我救赎了，他被视为此时此刻唯一的人选。现在，他的任务听起来可能有点枯燥。基本上，他必须摧毁法国舰队，但每个人都知道法国舰队不太可能出来被摧毁。所以这将是一个把他们困在土伦、封锁他们的问题。但这非常重要，因为正如你在休息前所说，这是一场对英国来说将在海上而非陆地上胜负的战争。
a couple of years earlier, and he is seen as the only man for the hour. Now, his task might sound a bit dull. Basically, he has to destroy the French fleet, but everyone knows the French fleet is very unlikely to come out to be destroyed. So it's going to be a question of bottling them up in Toulon, blockading them. But it's so important, because, as you said before the break, this is a war that for Britain will be won and lost on the seas, not on land.
因为如果法国人赢得了海上控制权，那就是如果他们获得了海峡的控制权。嗯，那是关键，不是吗？因为基本上，他们不需要赢得所有海洋的控制权。他们只需要赢得24小时的多佛海峡控制权？显然，英国人防范这种前景的焦点是海峡指挥部。但土伦的舰队也至关重要，因为如果他们确实设法突围，溜过封锁线，穿过直布罗陀海峡，那么他们就可以，你知道，加入对英国、爱尔兰或英国在加勒比海领地的入侵，这可能会起到一种可能的干扰作用。
because if the French were to win control of the seas, that's it if they get control of the channel. Well, that's the key, isn't it? Because basically, they don't need to win control of all the seas. They just need to win control of the Straits of Dover for, what, 24 hours? And obviously, the focus of guarding against that prospect for the British is the channel command. But the fleet in two long is crucial as well, because if they do manage to break out, to slip past the blockade, go out through the Straits of Gibraltar, Then they could, you know, join in the evasion of Britain or of Ireland or of Britain's holdings in the Caribbean, which would then act as a possible distraction.
你知道，舰队可能会从海峡被派往那里。所以纳尔逊面临着各种各样的危险。确实如此。而且封锁，我的意思是，封锁听起来不像战斗那么令人兴奋。但封锁确实非常、非常重要，既是防御性武器，也是进攻性武器。因为实际上，在接下来的12年里，英国的战略基本上是封锁法国的港口，窒息其贸易，挤压其经济，并真正说服法国的卫星国，如果他们与拿破仑决裂，他们会过得更好。
You know, fleets might be sent from the channel. So there's all kinds of jeopardy in play for Nelson. There is indeed. And a blockade, I mean, the blockade sounds not as exciting as a battle. But a blockade is really, really important, both as a defensive weapon and as an attacking one. Because actually, for the next 12 years, Britain's strategy will basically be to blockade France's ports, to suffocate its trade, to squeeze its economy. and really to persuade France's satellites that they'd be better off if they broke with Napoleon.
我们现在知道这个战略是有效的。这需要很长时间，但它迫使拿破仑构建了他的大陆体系。当俄国人打破大陆体系时，他入侵了俄国，他犯了一个可怕的错误，从莫斯科撤退，所有这些事情。所有这些你都可以追溯到英国那种基本上在海上挤压他的战略。当然，缺点是，当时没有人知道它会奏效，而且这确实是非常、非常艰苦的工作，不是吗？纳尔逊有11艘战列舰，15艘护卫舰，7艘支援舰，他必须保持它们在位。远离家乡，一直必须保持它们健康、吃饱、喝足，所有这些。嗯，事实是，从长远来看，
And we know now that this strategy works. It takes a long time, but it pushes Napoleon to construct his continental system. When the Russians break with the continental system, he invades Russia and he makes the terrible mistake, the retreat from Moscow, all of this kind of thing. All of this you can trace back to that British strategy of basically squeezing him by sea. The downside, though, of course, nobody knows it then, that it's going to work, and it's really, really hard work, isn't it? Nelson has 11 ships to the line, 15 frigates, seven support ships, and he has to keep them in play. Far from home, the whole time has to keep them healthy, well-fed, watered, all of this. Well, the thing is that in the long run,
纳尔逊和胜利号上的船员将有两年时间不会踏上陆地。所以那些船只一直都在外面。没有休息。没有休假。他花了，所以那是他在胜利号船舱或后甲板上的两年，在艾玛和霍拉蒂奥的肖像下工作。胜利号本身由他的老伙计哈迪管理。哈迪是，你不想惹哈迪。
Nelson and the crew on the victory will not set foot on dry land for two years. So those ships are permanently out there. There's no break. There's no leave. And he spent, so that's two years for him in the cabin or on the quarter deck of the victory, working beneath his portraits of Emma and Horatia. The victory itself is run by his old mate Hardy. And Hardy is, you don't want to get on the wrong side of Hardy.
哈迪在12个月内下令进行了204次鞭刑。他有一个名声，如果你做错了什么，那是可鞭刑的罪行，他会悄无声息地滑到你身后抓住你。所以他的绰号是“鬼魂”。他就像一个可怕的校长，基本上是这样，不是吗？又在表现不好了，霍兰。之后你会因为鞭刑来见我。所以我猜对纳尔逊来说，好处是他可以扮演仁慈的角色。
Hardy ordered 204 floggings in 12 months. And he had this reputation that if you were doing something wrong, that was a flogable offence, he would glide up unhurt behind you and apprehend you. And so his nickname was The Ghost. He's like a terrifying headmaster, basically, isn't he? It's behaving again, Holland. You'll see me afterwards for a flogging. And so I guess the upside for Nelson is it allows him to play the benevolent.
我不认为他在扮演，他吗？我的意思是，我认为那是他的一种本能。我认为他以一种男人的方式爱他的船员，显然。很多橡木之类的。但再次引用安德鲁·兰伯特的话，他在这方面太棒了。与纳尔逊共事就是爱他。即使是最坚强的退伍军人也无法抗拒他的勇气、承诺和魅力。他的同事是他的朋友，他期待他们的爱和忠诚，而不仅仅是服务。我担心听众可能会认为我们对纳尔逊的吹捧过头了。但我认为显然有魅力的品质
I don't think he's playing it. he? I mean, I think that's his kind of natural instincts. I think he loves his crew in a kind of manly way, obviously. Lots of oak and all that. But to quote Andrew Lambert again, he's so good on this. To work with Nelson was to love him. Even the most hard-bitten veterans were unable to resist his courage, commitment, and charisma. His colleagues were his friends, and he expected their love and loyalty, not mere service. And I worry that listeners may be thinking that we're over-egging the Nelson adulation. But I think there is clearly qualities of charisma
你必须不断强调，否则他的成就就说不通了。如果他只是一个严格的纪律执行者，他将无法做到这一点。事实是他能够激励人们去做他们否则可能不会做的事情。嗯，他通过，你知道，他们在海上待了很长很长时间。
that you have to keep harping upon because otherwise his achievements don't make sense. If he was just a strict disciplinarian, he wouldn't be able to carry this off. It's the fact that he is able to inspire people to do what otherwise they might not have done. Well, he does it by, you know, they're at sea for a heck of a long time.
他帮助他们组织。我的意思是，这听起来很琐碎。但他们有这些小戏和音乐评论，他会去看，他会巡视甲板并与男人们聊天，很多船长和海军上将不这样做，有一种距离。
He helps them to organise. I mean, it sounds petty. but they have these little plays and musical reviews and he will go to watch them he'll tour the decks and chat to the men and a lot of captains and admirals do not do this there is a distance
与纳尔逊的距离没那么大，而且当然，如果你在船上一次待两年，你需要被补给，纳尔逊不仅仅是关于冲劲和魅力，他也是一个非常、非常好的组织者。我的意思是，他知道他的船必须被
there is not so much of a distance with Nelson and also of course if you're on board a ship for two years at a time you need to be supplied and Nelson isn't all about dash and charisma he is also a very very good organizer of things I mean he knows that his ships have to be
补给。所以你写下来了。一年内，他们将需要1881吨面包。我的意思是，数百万的东西，加仑的啤酒，吨的牛肉、猪肉、豌豆、燕麦片、黄油、奶酪、醋。虽然其中很多是由英国德特福德的补给委员会提供的，但并非全部，纳尔逊必须采购大量材料，显然特别是水果，这可以防止坏血病。所以橙子和柠檬，以及臭名昭著的酸橙，这给了美国人对英国人的绰号，Limees。这是他从圣文森特那里学到的，他那种伟大的父亲形象，
supplied so you've written and down. In a year, they will need 1,881 tons of bread. I mean, just millions of stuff, gallons of beer, tons of beef, pork, peas, oatmeal, butter, cheese, vinegar. And although a lot of this is kind of supplied by the Vittling Board back in Deptford in England, not all of it is, Nelson has to source a lot of material, obviously kind of fruit in particular, which keeps scurvy at bay. So oranges and lemons and the notorious limes that, gives Americans the nickname for Englishmen, Limees. And this is something that he's picked up from St. Vincent, his kind of great father figure,
保持部下健康状况的重要性。所以纳尔逊对登上胜利号的一位医生说，所有军事服务中伟大的事情是健康，军官保持士兵健康比医生治愈他们更容易。他船上的补给官，直接在船上为他服务，最终从远至俄国的地方采购食物。皇家海军的伟大历史学家NAM罗杰说，纳尔逊的水手们，你知道，在这个时期，他们一定是世界上最健康的英国臣民群体。
the importance of maintaining his men in a condition of health. And so Nelson says to a physician that comes on board the victory, that the great thing in all military services health, and it is easier for an officer to keep men healthy than for a physician to cure them. His own Vettler on board the ship, who's serving him directly on board the ship, he ends up sourcing food from as far away as Russia. And NAM Roger, the great historian of the Royal Navy, says of Nelson Sailors, you know, in this period that they must have been the healthiest body of British subjects in the world.
因为即使没有任何细菌理论，在船上，他们明白登船，他们不允许休假的原因之一是因为在那里你可能会感染。他们不明白如何或为什么，但他们知道这很糟糕。因此，在某种意义上，你通过待在船上保持健康。基本上，胜利号上的人不会生病。嗯，这提醒我们纳尔逊不仅是一位伟大的战士。他实际上是一位伟大的官僚。
Because even though there isn't any germ theory, to be on board the ship, they understand that going aboard, one of the reasons that they don't allow leave is because there you might pick up infections. They don't understand how or why, but they know that it's bad. And therefore, in a sense, you're kind of, you're kept healthy by being on board the ship. And basically, people on board victory do not fall sick. Well, it's a reminder that Nelson's not just a great warrior. He's actually a great bureaucrat.
因为要做到这一切，你知道，你在摆弄账本，你在派遣员工，所有这些事情。他是一位优秀的管理者。他擅长所有这些事情。为了强调这一点，他们在土伦外等待了22个月，没有休息。现在，这不是纳尔逊喜欢做的事情。他不喜欢封锁。封锁非常无聊。他宁愿引诱敌人出来并彻底摧毁他们。
Because to do all this, you know, you're messing around with ledgers and you're sending out staff and all of this kind of thing. He's a good manager. He's good at all these kinds of things. And to emphasize the point, they're waiting off too long for 22 months without a break. Now, this is not what Nelson enjoys doing. He doesn't like blockades. Blockades are very boring. He would much rather lure the enemy out and destroy them completely.
这最终是他的计划，不是吗？那是他的作战计划。所以即使在维持封锁的同时，他也必须给法国人一点他们可能溜过去的嗅觉，否则他将永远无法进行他伟大的歼灭战。毫无疑问，听到这个你不会感到惊讶
And that's ultimately his plan, isn't it? That's his battle plan. So even while he's maintaining the blockade, he has to kind of give the French a sniff of the possibility that they might be able to slip past because otherwise he will never be able to have the battle of annihilation that is his great ambition. Undoubtedly will not surprise this to hear
纳尔逊花了很多时间为自己的健康而忧虑。他有所有的盗汗和心悸。他写信给艾玛说，我的视力在下降。我太瘦了，戒指从我手指上滑落。我对你的爱像海洋一样无边无际。这非常深刻和原创。他也写信给霍拉蒂奥，不是吗？是的，他是。
that Nelson spends a lot of time brooding about his health He's got all his night sweats and his heart palpitations. He's writing to Emma to say, my eyesight is failing. I'm so thin that the rings are slipping from my fingers. My love for you is as unbounded as the ocean. It's very profound and original. And he's writing to Horatia as well, isn't he? Yes, he is.
所以这很可爱，实际上。这真的很可爱。他在1803年10月写了第一封信给霍拉蒂奥。他说，我亲爱的孩子，收到这封来自你最深情的父亲的第一封信。所以他在那里很坦率。是的。他在承认她。然后几个月后，1804年1月，他寄出，她此时多大？
So this is lovely, actually. This is really lovely. He writes his first letter to Horatio in October 1803. He says, my dear child, receive this first letter from your most affection of father. So he's up front there. Yes. He's acknowledging her. And then a few months later, January 1804, he sends, how old is she at this point?
我想她大概三岁。是的。他寄给她一缕他的头发和一块手表，我允许你在周日佩戴，以及在非常特殊的日子里，当你打扮得体且表现得非常好时。我亲吻了它，并带着你的纳尔逊和勃朗特深情的祝福寄给你。向他自己的女儿吹嘘他的头衔。我还在吹嘘他的头衔，完全正确。但一直以来，他都在忧虑，在皮带上挣扎，等待这个机会，等待与法国舰队的摊牌。
She's like three, I think. Yeah. He sends her a lock of his hair and a watch, which I give you permission to wear on Sundays, and on very particular days when you're dressed and have behaved exceedingly well. I've kissed it and send it with the affectionate blessing of your Nelson and Bronte. Boasting about his titles to his own daughter. I'm still boating about his titles, exactly. But all the time he is brooding, straining at the leash, waiting for this chance, for this showdown with the French fleet.
因为他知道再多一次胜利可能就是彻底在海上粉碎他们所需要的全部。他们不能再有一次尼罗河战役了。他们可能想要再来一次，但就是这样。我认为他认为这会发生，因为他真诚地，我认为，将自己视为，你知道，神圣目的的代理人。所以当他写信给海军部时，他一次又一次地以这些术语来构建他的使命，这与海军中其他人写的信没有可比性。
Because he knows one more victory is probably all that it will take to crush them at sea for good completely. They can't have another battle of the Nile. They can maybe want more go, but that's it. I think he thinks it's going to happen because he genuinely, I think, seized himself as, you know, the agent of divine purpose. So when he writes letters to the admiralty, he frames his mission in these terms again and again in a way that has no comparison with letters written
我的意思是，重申一下，这确实要求他，即使在维持封锁时，也要给法国人一点他们可能溜过他的嗅觉。所以我们到了1804年的夏末。国内的阿丁顿政府已经倒台。
by other figures in the Navy. I mean, just to reiterate, this does require him, even as he's maintaining the blockade, to give the French the sniff of a chance that they might be able to get past him. So we get to the late summer of 1804. Addington's government back home has fallen.
皮特重新担任首相。有更多关于拿破仑在海峡沿岸建立入侵部队的报道。没有人知道拿破仑在计划什么。纳尔逊那年9月满46岁。他告诉朋友，他感觉自己像个在黑暗中迷路的人。他实际上在这一点上考虑休假，因为维持封锁的工作让他太累了。你可以感觉到在胜利号上22个月后，士气确实开始动摇。这是无聊、艰苦的工作。
Pitt is back as Prime Minister. there are more reports of Napoleon building up an invasion force on the Channel Coast. Nobody knows what Napoleon is planning. Nelson in September that year turned 46. He said to friends that he felt like a man lost in the dark. He's actually thinking at this point of going on leave because he's so tired from the work of maintaining the blockade. And you can sense on the victory after 22 months, morale is really beginning to fray. This is boring, gruelling work.
航海日志之类的显示，因为行为不端而受到的鞭刑更多了。因为人们感到无聊，所以有更多的醉酒、傲慢和不服从事件。他们厌倦了待在那里。他们在这个阶段厌倦了彼此。所以鬼魂有更多的滑行。是的，鬼魂峰会，辉煌的时刻。然后是一个重磅炸弹。英国人得知波拿巴与西班牙达成了一项秘密协议。
The logbooks and whatnot show that there are more floggings for bad behavior. There are more incidents of drunkenness and insolence and insubordination because people are bored. They're sick of being there. They're sick of each other at this stage. So a lot more gliding for the ghost. Yes, the Ghost Summit, brilliant time. And then a bombshell. The British learn that Bonaparte has struck a secret deal with Spain.
西班牙人同意他们将每年支付一千万法郎的补贴，他们摆脱它的唯一方法是如果他们真的加入法国一方的战争。威廉·皮特基本上命令对南美宝藏舰队进行先发制人的打击。这变得非常糟糕。一艘船，梅赛德斯号，没有投降。他们向它发射了警告射击。他们击中了弹药库。梅赛德斯号爆炸了。200人丧生。西班牙随后对英国宣战，这对英国的战争计划来说是一场灾难。因为虽然西班牙人不再是他们曾经拥有的力量，但当你结合法国和西班牙舰队时，他们以102艘战列舰对83艘战列舰的数量超过了皇家海军。而且，这也是为什么纳尔逊的补给官必须开始去俄国和其他地方，因为西班牙所有的水果现在都被禁运了。
The Spanish have agreed they will hand over a subsidy of ten. of millions of francs a year, and the only way for them to get out of it is if they actually join the war on the French side. William Pitt orders basically a preemptive strike against the South American treasure fleet. It goes horribly wrong. A ship, the Mercedes, doesn't surrender. They fire warning shots at it. They hit the magazine. The Mercedes explodes. 200 people are killed. Spain then declares war on Britain, a catastrophe for the British war plan. Because although the Spanish are not the power that they once were, when you combine the French and Spanish fleets, they outnumber the Royal Navy by 102 ships of the line to 83 ships of the line. And also, this is why Nelson's Bittler has to start going to Russia and other such places, because all the fruit in Spain is now embargoed.
完全正确。然后汤姆，你说纳尔逊想引诱他们出来。所以他总是给他们一点点机会的嗅觉，不是吗，法国人？现在，在1805年1月，一个破碎的发展。他在撒丁岛海岸外补给。这是一个下雨、刮风的日子。然后穿过大风，他看到他留下来监视土伦法国人的两艘护卫舰向他驶来。
Exactly. And then Tom, you were saying Nelson wants to lure them out. So he's always left them the little sniff of a chance, hasn't he, the French? Now, in January 1805, a shattering development. He is off the coast of Sardinia taking on provisions. It's a rainy, windy day. And then through the gale, he sees two frigates that he'd left watching the French at too long coming towards him.
他们有耸人听闻的消息。当他一直在获取补给时，法国人终于离开了土伦。没有人知道他们去了哪里。这是最著名的海军历史追逐战的开火信号。我的意思是，唯一能与我们竞争的，当然是纳尔逊在导致尼罗河战役的战役中对拿破仑的追击。他不知道，就像尼罗河一样，对吧？
And they have sensational news. While he's been getting provisions, the French have finally left too long. And nobody knows where they have gone. And this is the firing of the gun for the most celebrated. chase in naval history. I mean, and the only one that would rival us, of course, is Nelson's pursuit of Napoleon back in the campaign that culminates in the Battle of the Nile. And he doesn't know, as with the Nile, right?
我们知道他们要去埃及。纳尔逊当时不知道。现在，这一次，他再次不知道法国人可能要去哪里。事实上，他认为他们可能又要去埃及了。所以他出发了，冲向亚历山大。他花了七天时间到达那里，他们不在那里。他穿过地中海回到撒丁岛，在那里他听说他们已经折回土伦的法国人那里了。
We know that they were going to Egypt. Nelson didn't know it then. Now, this time, once again, he has no idea where the French could be going. And in fact, he thinks they're probably going to Egypt again. So off he goes, rushes off to Alexandria. Seven days it takes him to get there, they're not there. He goes back across the Mediterranean, back to Sardinia, and there he hears that they have doubled back the French to Toulon.
所以他为他们设了另一个陷阱。他佯装向巴塞罗那进发，这样法国人就会认为他在守卫西线。但他偷偷溜回东部，希望他们会去东部，你看。他在撒丁岛海岸外等待他们。然后在1805年4月4日，另一艘护卫舰再次穿过雨水向他驶来，菲比号，他们说，是的，法国人再次离开了土伦，但他们知道你在计划什么。他们发现了你的计划。他们向南和向西绕过马略卡岛，然后消失了。所以现在纳尔逊，他向北非海岸散开他的
So then he sets another trap for them. He feints towards Barcelona so that the French will think he's guarding the Western route. But then he sneaks back east, hoping that they will go east, you see. And he waits for them off the coast of Sardinia. And then on the 4th of April 1805, another frigate comes. towards him through the rain again, the Phoebe, and they say, yeah, the French have left too long again, but they knew what you were planning. They found out about your scheme. They have gone sort of south and west past Mallorca, and then they vanished. So now Nelson, he spreads out his
舰队，就像一张试图抓住他们的网。但没有他们的踪迹。他精疲力竭。他很沮丧。他告诉朋友他感觉半死不活。他感觉半死不活。非常、非常悲惨，他说。然后在4月19日，他们经过一位商船船长，他说，10天前，我看到一支法国舰队穿过直布罗陀海峡进入大西洋。对纳尔逊来说，这是一个令人难以置信的沉重打击。他完全被算计和机动了，法国人已经逃进了大西洋。谁知道他们接下来要去哪里？
fleet towards the coast of North Africa, like a net trying to catch them. But there's no sign of them. And he's exhausted. He's depressed. He tells friends he feels half dead. He feels half dead. very, very miserable, he says. And then on the 19th of April, they pass a merchant captain who says, 10 days earlier, I saw a French fleet passing through the Straits of Gibraltar into the Atlantic. And for Nelson, this is an unbelievably heavy blow. He has been completely outthought and outmaneuvered, and the French have escaped into the Atlantic. And who knows where they're then going?
是去英国吗？是去爱尔兰吗？还是去加勒比海的伟大领地？嗯，因为也，现在进入大西洋后，他们可以与西班牙人联系。是的。所以他们可以实现拥有联合舰队的梦想。这把我们带到了我们知道而纳尔逊不知道的事情。所以法国人在计划什么？
Is it to Britain? Is it to Ireland? Or is it to the great holdings in the Caribbean? Well, because also, having now gone into the Atlantic, they can link up with the Spanish. Yeah. So they can fulfil this dream of having a combined fleet. And this brings us to what we know and Nelson doesn't know. So what are the French planning?
法国舰队的指挥官是这位名叫皮埃尔-查尔斯·维尔纳夫的贵族军官，他来自一个古老的海军家族。沙皇保罗一世不会喜欢他。或者也许他会，因为维尔纳夫是古老的权利，马耳他骑士。是的，所以英国现在控制马耳他的事实，你知道，维尔纳夫有皮肤在游戏中。
The commander of the French fleet is this aristocratic officer called Pierre-Charles-Vilnerve, who came from an old naval family. The Tsar, Paul I would not have liked. him. Or maybe he would, because Villeneuve was by ancient right, a knight of Malta. Yeah, and so the fact that the British now control Malta, you know, Villeneuve has skin in the game.
嗯，他有皮肤在游戏中，因为维尔纳夫本人在某些方面实际上是一个相当有吸引力的人。他非常有礼貌和老练，他是一个相当内向和谨慎的人。他在尼罗河战役中指挥了法国后卫，如果你听了第一季，你会记得他实际上逃脱了。与其说，哦，做得好，你逃脱了，法国公众舆论说，看看你，你这个可怕的懦夫，其他所有人都被杀或被俘，而你逃跑了。而且他也是贵族背景，这再次并不完全是一个帮助。完全正确。现在，维尔纳夫正在遵循拿破仑·波拿巴在巴黎制定的计划，他现在当然已经加冕自己为法国皇帝。拿破仑从这个计划中到底想要什么真的不清楚。所以他一直在改变主意，实际上我在这些纳尔逊书中的一本中看到的一个估计是拿破仑
Well, he has skin in the game as well, because Villeneuve himself is actually in some ways quite an attractive man. He's very polite and sophisticated and he's quite a reserved man and cautious. He had commanded the French rear at the Battle of the Nile and if you listened to Season
嗯，他自己也身陷其中，因为维尔纳夫本人在某些方面其实是一个很有魅力的人。他非常有礼貌、世故，而且是一个相当内敛和谨慎的人。他曾在尼罗河海战中指挥法国后卫部队，如果你听过第一季，
1, you'll remember that he actually got away. And rather than saying, oh, well done, you got away, French public opinion says, look at you, you dreadful coward, everybody else was killed or captured, and you ran away. And also he's of aristocratic background, which again isn't entirely a help. Exactly. Now, Villeneuve is following a plan that was devised in Paris by Napoleon Bonaparte, who is now, of course, crowned himself emperor of the French. What Napoleon exactly wanted from this plan is really unclear. So he kept changing his mind and actually one estimate I saw in one of these Nelson books is Napoleon
你会记得他实际上逃脱了。法国公众舆论并没有说“哦，干得好，你逃出来了”，而是说“看看你，你这个可怕的懦夫，其他人都被杀或被俘了，而你却逃跑了”。而且他出身贵族，这对他来说也并非完全是好事。没错。现在，维尔纳夫正在执行拿破仑·波拿巴在巴黎制定的计划，拿破仑当然已经加冕为法国皇帝。拿破仑从这个计划中到底想要什么，其实并不清楚。所以他一直在改变主意，事实上，我在其中一本纳尔逊传记中看到的一个估计是，拿破仑
had eight different plans in 12 months after September 1804. And one of them was the kind of the old fantasy of, you know, taking Egypt and marching on India. And the thing is Napoleon doesn't really know much about the sea and naval affairs. So his admirals, when they see his latest plan, often their hearts rather sinks because they think, oh, this is just not possible. Well, I mean, And that obviously includes Villeneuve himself, who thinks, no, these plans are mad. And also the Minister of the Navy, who's a guy called Deni Decre, who also thought it was mad. And he, too, like Villeneuve, had fought at the Nile. He had then been captured after trying to break Nelson's blockade of Malta.
在1804年9月之后的12个月里，他制定了八种不同的计划。其中一个计划是那种老掉牙的幻想，你知道的，就是占领埃及并进军印度。问题是拿破仑对海洋和海军事务并不太了解。所以他的海军上将们在看到他最新的计划时，内心往往会感到沉重，因为他们认为这根本不可能实现。当然，这显然包括维尔纳夫本人，他认为这些计划简直是疯了。还有海军大臣，一个叫德尼·德克雷的人，他也认为这很疯狂。他和维尔纳夫一样，也曾在尼罗河之战中作战。他在试图打破纳尔逊对马耳他的封锁后被俘。
And after his capture, he had dined with Nelson himself. So he really understands what the French are up against in Nelson and the Royal Navy. To a degree, I think that Napoleon just doesn't understand at all. I don't think Napoleon does understand. Now, what's Napoleon's ultimate goal? His ultimate goal is obviously what thing you were talking about before, Tom, which is getting across the channel, getting an army across the channel, and launching an invasion of Britain.
被俘后，他曾与纳尔逊本人共进晚餐。所以他非常了解法国人在纳尔逊和皇家海军面前处于什么样的境地。在某种程度上，我认为拿破仑根本就不理解。我不认为拿破仑理解。那么，拿破仑的最终目标是什么？他的最终目标显然就是你之前提到的，汤姆，那就是跨越海峡，将一支军队运过海峡，并对英国发动入侵。
A lot of historians now say he never had the transports, he never had the control of the channel, this was never a realistic prospect. However, what Napoleon seems to be saying to Villeneuve is, look, I want you to get out of the Mediterranean, into the Atlantic, I want you to link up with the Spanish. I want you to strike west towards the Caribbean, towards Britain's Caribbean colonies, lay waste to them or whatever. That will terrify the British. That would draw the Royal Navy out of the Channel, possibly, ideally, in pursuit. As soon as the British have come out, race back to Europe across the Atlantic,
许多历史学家现在说他从来没有足够的运输船，从来没有控制过海峡，这从来都不是一个现实的前景。然而，拿破仑似乎对维尔纳夫说的是，听着，我要你离开地中海，进入大西洋，我要你与西班牙人会合。我要你向西进发，前往加勒比海，前往英国的加勒比殖民地，摧毁它们或者做点什么。那会吓坏英国人。这可能会引诱皇家海军离开海峡，理想情况下，去追击你们。一旦英国人出来，就立刻横跨大西洋赶回欧洲，
link up with the other big French fleet at Brest, win control of the channel. I will have my invasion force ready at Boulogne. We can bring them across. Bang, job done. And he tells one of his generals, all I need is a favourable wind in order to plant the imperial eagle on the Tower of London. And that is a very complicated scheme, isn't it? involving vast distances, communications across an immense ocean. And you can see why both the minister and Villeneuve himself thought this was impractical. What are you going to do when you got an emperor telling you to do things? Yeah. I mean, Villenev said, not only is it a mad plan, but even if he was a man, but even If they're British or a third weaker than we are, they're still beat us because they're much better than us.
与布雷斯特的另一支法国大舰队会合，夺取海峡的控制权。我会在布洛涅准备好我的入侵部队。我们可以把他们运过去。砰，大功告成。他告诉他的一位将军，我只需要一阵顺风，就能把帝国之鹰插在伦敦塔上。这是一个非常复杂的计划，不是吗？涉及巨大的距离，跨越广阔海洋的通信。你可以看出为什么海军大臣和维尔纳夫本人都认为这不切实际。当皇帝命令你做事时，你该怎么办？是的。我的意思是，维尔纳夫说，这不仅是一个疯狂的计划，而且即使他是一个人，但即使他们是英国人，或者比我们弱三分之一，他们仍然会打败我们，因为他们比我们强得多。
We'll be the laughing stock of Europe. That's the fighting spirit you want. But obviously, he can't say that's the emperor, can you? No, of course not. So, on the 9th of April, Villeneuve, as instructed, had linked up at Cadiz with the Spanish fleet under Federico Carlos Gravina. So Gravina was actually a Sicilian by birth, wasn't he? Born in Palermo, a place close to Nelson's heart. and he had actually served
我们将成为欧洲的笑柄。这就是你想要的战斗精神。但显然，他不能对皇帝说这些，对吧？不，当然不能。所以，在4月9日，维尔纳夫按照指示，在加的斯与费德里科·卡洛斯·格拉维纳率领的西班牙舰队会合了。所以格拉维纳实际上是西西里人，不是吗？出生在巴勒莫，一个离纳尔逊心很近的地方。他实际上曾服役于
this, I didn't, I only recently discovered this fact, it's a great fact. He had actually served alongside Nelson's mentor, Admiral Hood, in the Siege of Toulon, when the Spanish were on the other side. Well, the Spanish keep kind of changing sides, don't they? And in due course, they will change sides again, and they'll team up with Wellington.
这一点，我之前不知道，我最近才发现这个事实，这是一个很棒的事实。他实际上曾与纳尔逊的导师胡德海军上将一起在土伦围城战中服役，当时西班牙人站在另一边。嗯，西班牙人一直在换边站，不是吗？在适当的时候，他们会再次换边，并与威灵顿结盟。
So, very much in play. And Gravina is a, I mean, the thing with Trafalgar, which we'll be getting to, is both Gravina and Villeneuve are in their way. They're quite likable character. I think. Gravina is a very corkly man, kind of experienced sailor. He's good at his job. They have joined up their fleets. They're going to go west across the Atlantic. They're going to hit at the sugar islands on which Britain's prosperity partly depends. By the time Nelson realizes what's going on,
所以，这非常关键。关于特拉法尔加，我们稍后会讲到，格拉维纳和维尔纳夫在某种程度上都是挺讨人喜欢的角色。我认为是这样。格拉维纳是一个非常干练的人，经验丰富的水手。他很擅长自己的工作。他们已经合并了舰队。他们要横跨大西洋向西进发。他们要打击英国繁荣部分依赖的糖岛。当纳尔逊意识到发生了什么事时，
he is shattered. Of course, he's been scouring the Mediterranean for months. He hasn't been sleeping. He's been alone on the quarterdeck, staring out into the night in driving rain. His, you know, his steward and all his kind of staff are very worried about him. But he can't stop. He has to keep going because the Caribbean trade depends upon him now. So he races through the pillars of Hercules. He picks up the Atlantic trade winds and he rushes west. And by the 4th of June, an extraordinary feat, he has reached Barbados. And there he hears that Villeneuve had reached Martinique three weeks earlier. But Villeneuve has not launched a major operation against the British Islands. Why not? Obviously, because Napoleon's orders are, you should scare the British,
他已经精疲力竭了。当然，他已经在地中海搜寻了几个月。他一直没睡。他独自站在后甲板上，在倾盆大雨中凝视着黑夜。他的管家和所有随从都非常担心他。但他不能停下来。他必须继续前进，因为加勒比海的贸易现在依赖于他。所以他冲过赫拉克勒斯之柱。他抓住了大西洋的信风，向西疾驰。到6月4日，这是一个非凡的壮举，他到达了巴巴多斯。在那里，他听说维尔纳夫三周前已经到达了马提尼克。但维尔纳夫并没有对英国岛屿发动大规模行动。为什么不呢？显然，因为拿破仑的命令是，你应该吓唬英国人，
lure them out, but then double back. In other words, he's not going to begin any big operations. So now the focus has moved to the Caribbean, the islands of the Caribbean, and Nelson is kind of wandering through these islands. He tracks Villeneuve to Trinidad, to Port of Spain. and he's convinced he's going to find him in Trinidad. In fact, Nelson was so convinced that he ordered the ships cleared for action, thinking this will be the showdown. But when he gets to Port of Spain, the French and Spanish are not there. I mean, just imagine in London we might have had Port of Spain Square rather than Trafalgar Square.
引诱他们出来，然后折返。换句话说，他不会开始任何大的行动。所以现在焦点已经转移到了加勒比海，加勒比海的岛屿，纳尔逊正在这些岛屿中徘徊。他追踪维尔纳夫到特立尼达，到西班牙港。他确信会在特立尼达找到他。事实上，纳尔逊如此确信，以至于他下令船只做好战斗准备，认为这将是决战。但当他到达西班牙港时，法国人和西班牙人并不在那里。我的意思是，想象一下，在伦敦我们可能就会有西班牙港广场而不是特拉法尔加广场了。
That would be a good name though, no? Yeah, I like it. It has a ring. Now, what's been going on in the combined fleet? Actually, Villeneuve and Gravina get on quite well for kind of two rival commanders. of the same fleet, but they don't have a clear plan that they believe in because they're both kind of think Napoleon's plan is mad. And has our old friend Yellow Fever started spreading? Yes, it has. So the Spanish are riddled with yellow fever. He says, chuckling. Yeah. Well, they already think they're going to lose, don't they? I mean, that's the other thing.
那会是个好名字，不是吗？是的，我喜欢。听起来不错。那么，联合舰队那边发生了什么？其实，维尔纳夫和格拉维纳作为同一舰队的两位竞争指挥官，相处得还不错，但他们没有一个他们相信的明确计划，因为他们都认为拿破仑的计划是疯狂的。我们的老朋友黄热病开始传播了吗？是的，已经开始了。所以西班牙人深受黄热病困扰。他笑着说。是的。嗯，他们已经认为自己会输了，不是吗？我的意思是，那是另一回事。
The French field nerve has already publicly stated. If we meet the British, they're bound to defeat us. Morale is not tip-top. No. the 10th of June, which is only six days after Nelson had first reached Barbados, Villeneuve decided to abandon the Caribbean and to head back east. But that's, I mean, that was what the orders had been given by Napoleon. It was the orders, but I think the orders were that they would turn back east in the spirit of martial vigor. London, here we come.
法国舰队维尔纳夫已经公开表示。如果我们遇到英国人，他们一定会打败我们。士气并不高昂。不。6月10日，也就是纳尔逊第一次到达巴巴多斯仅六天后，维尔纳夫决定放弃加勒比海，向东折返。但我的意思是，这就是拿破仑下达的命令。那是命令，但我认为命令是让他们以一种英勇的精神向东折返。伦敦，我们来了。
Rather than limp miserably back convicted with yellow fever. Everyone dying. Yeah. And Nelson, of course, gaining on them all the time. So three days later, Nelson followed suits, sailing east from. Antigua. It was an incredible job by Nelson to have pulled off this chase and to be so close behind them. I mean, he has been at sea for months racing, pushing his men to the absolute limit. And he has, in his own mind, saved the Caribbean colonies because they haven't really been
而不是因为黄热病而悲惨地蹒跚而回。每个人都在死去。是的。而纳尔逊当然一直在追赶他们。所以三天后，纳尔逊也效仿，从安提瓜向东航行。纳尔逊完成这次追击并紧随其后，这是一项令人难以置信的工作。我的意思是，他在海上奔波了几个月，把他的部下推向了极限。而且，在他自己的心目中，他拯救了加勒比殖民地，因为他们并没有真正能够
able to launch any serious operations against them. The French and Spanish threat has been dispelled. And he's done an incredible job. And in fact, the Caribbean sugar planters are suffused with gratitude to Nelson, aren't they? Sure. However, against that, he hasn't actually caught up with Vilna, has it? No. I mean, that's the thing. Nelson has very high standards for himself.
对他们发动任何严重的行动。法国和西班牙的威胁已经被消除。他做了一项令人难以置信的工作。事实上，加勒比海的糖业种植园主对纳尔逊充满了感激，不是吗？当然。然而，反过来说，他并没有真正追上维尔纳夫，对吧？不。我的意思是，这就是问题所在。纳尔逊对自己有很高的标准。
He thinks he should have caught up with them. And he writes in his journal that he feels very, very low, that he hasn't caught up with Vilnav. Well, because what if they are heading up the channel? What has the Channel Fleet, the British Channel Fleet, been doing? I mean, he doesn't know. He's operating blind here. And, of course, you fear the worst, don't you?
他认为他应该追上他们。他在日记中写道，他感到非常非常低落，因为他没有追上维尔纳夫。嗯，因为如果他们正前往海峡呢？英国海峡舰队一直在做什么？我的意思是，他不知道。他在这里盲目行动。当然，你会担心最坏的情况，不是吗？
You do. So now he's heading back east across the Atlantic towards Gibraltar. Who knows where the French and Spanish have gone? He and his men are absolutely shattered. They have not had time to stop for supplies or fresh water. So he has had to, for example, cut the water rations to less than half the norm. And this is the hottest time of the year in midsummer in the Caribbean. I mean, they must be so sunburned and hungry and thirsty that again, the records show the punishment record. would show that there are lots of cases of people being drunk or fighting or insubordination because basically their morale is, I mean, they're frayed almost to kind of breaking points, I think, the bonds between them. They finally reached Gibraltar, having made incredible time on the 19th of July. And for the first time in two years, Nelson sets foot on dry land. And here he hears reports that Villeneuve has taken refuge. in the port of Ferrol, which is in Galicia, in northern Spain. And so with Villeneuve back in port, Nelson thinks, well, finally I can take the chance for a break.
确实。所以现在他正向东横跨大西洋前往直布罗陀。谁知道法国人和西班牙人去了哪里？他和他的部下已经彻底崩溃了。他们没有时间停下来补充补给或淡水。所以他不得不，例如，将水配给量削减到正常水平的一半以下。这是加勒比海仲夏时节最热的时候。我的意思是，他们一定被晒伤了，又饿又渴，记录显示惩罚记录显示有很多醉酒、打架或违抗命令的案例，因为基本上他们的士气，我的意思是，他们之间的纽带几乎到了崩溃的边缘，我想。他们终于在7月19日到达了直布罗陀，创造了令人难以置信的时间。两年来，纳尔逊第一次踏上陆地。在这里，他听到报告说维尔纳夫已经在费罗尔港避难，该港位于西班牙北部的加利西亚。所以随着维尔纳夫回到港口，纳尔逊想，好吧，终于我可以休息一下了。
Because he can set the blockade up, bottle them up, and rely on his men to maintain the blockade while he goes back to England. To England, exactly. So on the month later, on the 19th of August, 1805, Nelson steps ashore at Portsmouth for the first time since he left England to begin this. whole operation, and he picks up a coach bound for Merton and for Emma and for home. And ahead of him, there is just one more voyage and one more battle, the Day of Destiny at Trafalgar. And although Nelson could hardly have known it, he has just two months and two days to live. And Dominic, we will be telling the story of those two months and two months. days, the story of Nelson's last two months, the greatest drama possibly in all naval history,
因为他可以建立封锁，把他们困住，并依靠他的部下维持封锁，而他自己则回到英国。回到英国，没错。所以一个月后，1805年8月19日，纳尔逊自离开英国开始整个行动以来，第一次在朴茨茅斯上岸，他搭上了一辆前往默顿、前往艾玛、前往家的马车。在他面前，只有最后一次航行和最后一场战斗，特拉法尔加的命运之日。虽然纳尔逊几乎不可能知道，但他只剩下两个月零两天可活了。多米尼克，我们将讲述那两个月零两天故事，纳尔逊最后两个月的故事，这可能是所有海军史上最伟大的戏剧，
I would say in all British history next week. If you just can't wait, well, if you're a member of the Restless History Club, you don't have to wait. And if you'd like to be a member of the Restless History Club, you can go and sign up at the Restless History.com. And if you do that, then tomorrow you'll get an additional super soreaway bonus in the form of Mary Beard talking to me about Julius Caesar. But either way, we will be back with the final two episodes of this epic series coming up, the Battle of Trafalgar. Goodbye.
我会说是整个英国历史上最伟大的，下周。如果你等不及了，嗯，如果你是“历史其余部分俱乐部”的成员，你就不必等了。如果你想成为“历史其余部分俱乐部”的成员，你可以去therestishistory.com注册。如果你那样做了，明天你就会得到一个额外的超级奖励，玛丽·比尔德将和我谈论尤利乌斯·凯撒。但无论如何，我们将带着这个史诗系列最后两集回来，即将到来的特拉法尔加海战。再见。
Bye-bye. Hello, I'm Gordon Carrera, National Security Journalist. And I'm David McCloskey, former CIA analyst, turned spy novelist. And together we're the host of another goalhanger show called The Rest is Classified, where we bring you the best stories from the world of secrets and spas. It's right, Gordon, and our new six-part series tells the story of John F. Kennedy, the CIA, and Cuba. It's a covert war of botched invasions, mafia deals, and CIA plots to kill Fidel Castro.
再见。你好，我是国家安全记者戈登·卡雷拉。我是大卫·麦克洛斯基，前中央情报局分析师，转行成为间谍小说家。我们一起主持另一个Goalhanger节目，叫《其余部分是机密》，在那里我们为你带来来自秘密和间谍世界的最好故事。没错，戈登，我们的新六集系列讲述了约翰·F·肯尼迪、中央情报局和古巴的故事。这是一场由拙劣的入侵、黑手党交易和中央情报局暗杀菲德尔·卡斯特罗的阴谋组成的秘密战争。
The CIA has a secret army, the mob has a vendetta, and Kennedy is caught in the middle. So what if the answer to the 20th century's most infamous assassination is found not on the streets of Dallas, but 90 miles off the coast of Florida? And for our declassified club members, oh, you're in for a treat because we've gone even further. They have an exclusive three-part miniseries that digs deep into these conspiracies. We've also got as part of that a jaw-dropping episode with Anthony Scaramucci, the Mooch himself. who says he has insider evidence that ties the mob directly to Lee Harvey Oswald. All this sounds good to you. You can listen to The Rest is Classified wherever you get your podcast.
中央情报局有一支秘密军队，黑帮有仇恨，而肯尼迪夹在中间。那么，如果20世纪最臭名昭著的暗杀事件的答案不是在达拉斯的街头，而是在离佛罗里达海岸90英里的地方呢？对于我们的解密俱乐部成员，哦，你们有福了，因为我们走得更远。他们有一个独家的三集迷你剧，深入挖掘这些阴谋。我们还有一集令人瞠目结舌的节目，嘉宾是安东尼·斯卡拉穆奇，那个“Mooch”本人，他说他有内部证据将黑帮直接与李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德联系起来。所有这些听起来不错。你可以在任何你获取播客的地方收听《其余部分是机密》。
If you think you know who killed JFK, think you can. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你认为你知道是谁杀了肯尼迪，认为你可以。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。